- Pop, pop, pop.
- Can we all do the mouth?
(mouths popping)
- Are we good?
- Shut up everyone!
- Yay.
(bright upbeat music)
- Hello and welcome to another
episode of Trash Taste.
I am your host for today, Garnt,
and with me, as usual, are the boys, Joey,
and whoever this baby man is right now.
And-
- 15 Year old, Connor.
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
- We've got 15 year old, Connor.
And once again, we have
another special guest with us.
If you remember, it has
been exactly one year?
- Oh, no, a little
close, very close though.
- Yeah, pretty close.
I think it's been a
little bit over a year,
but I'm glad to see you guys again.
Always happy to appear as a
guest, if you will have me.
- Who are you? Introduce yourself.
- I guess I should do that,
people that don't know.
(Mori and Garnt chuckles)
Hi, my name is Mori Calliope
and I am from hololive
English, first-generation Myth,
and basically, I'm the first
apprentice of the Grim Reaper,
but I mostly do music
and streaming these days.
So yeah, thank you very
much for having me.
I have been on the
podcast before, actually,
this is round number
two, highly requested by-
- Couldn't get enough.
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
- Yeah, we were just at the
Conbini and we were like,
"Oh, Calli, yo, come on, we
got your call, come here."
- Yeah sure.
- You got a new outfit,
looking great, by the way.
- Thank you very much.
- You even got your own mic as well.
- You brought your own microphone.
(Garnt laughs)
- I did, I did, I love that I decided to.
- Is that the moment you were in?
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
- Yeah, wanted it to be
as convenient as possible.
- Top quality.
- Top quality, top quality.
- Nice.
- Yeah, so how've you been?
It's been like a good year.
- Oh man, tired but good.
(Garnt chuckles)
Tired but good, I think.
(Mori chuckles)
- Could you be more tired than last time?
I remember last time you were like,
"Grim Reaper has a part-time
job and another part-time job."
- You were working three
jobs at the time, right?
- [Connor] Yeah, it was insane.
- I was, I was.
I was super busy,
but then I finally got into a position
where I could focus completely
on what I'm doing now,
so I'm very lucky.
- [Joey] Hell yeah, nice.
(Mori chuckles)
- I'm very lucky.
And I'm glad that it turned out that way
because yeah, I definitely would've died,
which is ironic considering who I am.
(Garnt chuckles)
So it would have been a bad situation,
but interestingly enough,
I feel now that I'm
controlling my own schedule,
I'm busier than I was before.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause you're filling in all the blanks,
that's how it works.
- [Mori] Exactly.
- You're like, "Oh, I have one
second free at this moment,
I could schedule a meeting."
- [Mori] I could stream here.
(Garnt and Mori chuckles)
- Yeah, I remember the
last time talking to you,
you were just like, "Yeah,
I'm working three jobs,
I kind of feel bad if I quit one."
And I think it took a
month for you to realize,
yeah, that's just not doable.
- [Connor] That's just somehow (laughing).
(Mori laughs)
- That was a bad idea.
- Just impossible.
- It's a good thing to
honor your commitments.
But there's also a point where honoring
your commitments actively
fucks yourself over.
- [Mori] Not good.
- So you can always just be like,
"Oh, this just isn't working out for me.
I'm gonna not do this, I think."
- I think the last time you
were on the podcast you had,
I think, 300,000 subs
or something like that.
- Yeah, how long have you been
doing VTubing at that point?
How long had that been?
- Oh, let's see.
I think it had only been
about two or three months
since we all had debut together.
- Yeah, you were a baby
back then, I remember.
(Connor laughs)
I think hololive English just
got announced a few months
before we started filming that episode,
so it was like super, super fresh.
- And now you're at how many subs now?
- I think we just hit
1,750,000 subscribers recently.
- [Connor] Woo.
Well, maybe, I don't know.
(hands clapping)
(Garnt celebrates)
- Big up.
- [Mori] But thank you, I'm doing my best.
- It's pretty impressive
after a year, honestly,
to any capacity.
- I wish I could hit that in a year.
- [Joey] Yeah, right?
- My God.
- [Joey] It's great.
- I mean, I do think a lot of it has
to do with my music, personally.
- [Joey] Oh, yeah.
- Because I think that,
that's where the majority
of my fans come from.
In fact, I see a lot
of comments these days
saying, "I don't really
know what a VTuber is,
but I like Mori's music."
So that's cool.
(Garnt and Mori chuckles)
That's always, I'm happy
to see that as well.
- Does it feel like a year?
Or does it feel like five years?
- It's like it changes every day.
Every day I feel a different way about it.
I feel like, maybe for example,
yesterday I was reflecting back and man,
time has gone by so fast,
but the previous week I was like,
"Man, what a long year it's been."
(Garnt chuckles)
Have I been doing this
for five years, maybe?
- YouTube is like a reverse
hyperbolic time chamber.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah it is.
- It's like, "Oh God, I
feel like I've done this
for a decade."
It's like, "Oh, it's been two
months, aw shit, all right."
- Yeah, sometimes as a YouTuber,
it feels like five years or five months,
I can't tell sometimes.
- I mean, it must feel like
(laughing) ages for you.
- Oh my fuck, I've been-
- You've been doing this for how long now?
- I feel like I've aged a
hundred years on YouTube.
(Joey laughs)
My God.
- Yeah, there are some
OGs, that's for sure.
(Mori chuckles)
- Oh, go on, go on.
- Oh, sorry, I completely forgot
what I was going to say now.
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
- I'm sorry I interrupted
you from hosting.
- Come on, we've been doing
this for how many episodes now?
- Bad host, bad host.
- No problem.
Man, but I do have to say though,
one thing that has
really made it seem like
it's been a long time is
realizing just how little I knew
at the beginning.
- Yeah, yeah, how much have you learnt?
- Oh, God, I mean, honestly,
to be completely real with you guys,
as I mentioned before,
I did a lot of music
stuff before this as well,
but I feel like this year
I've put out more content
than I have in my entire
career before this year.
- Oh, yeah.
- And I really learned
a lot about work ethic.
And what it means to consistently
put out content every single day.
- Yeah, that's something
you don't really think
about when you get into
the online creation field,
is that it is a job and you
have to schedule your job.
- Just call Garnt out, just call him out.
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
(Connor chuckles)
You guys like content?
Aw shit,
I'm gonna upload the-
- [Garnt] Content?
What is that?
- Scheduling, what's that?
- Guys, I'm working on
something big, I swear to God.
(Mori laughs)
- Everybody's got to-
- Maybe this fifth Fate
video will be the one.
- Five months later.
(Mori laughs)
(Garnt and Joey chuckles)
- I feel like everyone has
a different interpretation
of what content consists of.
(Garnt laughs)
Like (laughing)-
- She's learning.
(all laughs)
It really depends on the person.
For example, I've seen plenty of requests
for a sleeping stream.
And that's not really
what I'm interested in,
but I've seen plenty of
others do it and I guess,
quote, unquote, do it well.
- How's that going on?
You've done that, right?
- Yeah, you've done that.
(Mori laughs)
- When I see VTubers sleep,
I'm like, "Oh, that's
cheating, that's cheating."
- Yeah, you can, like I-
- I'm like, come on,
unless there's a chance
that you could expose
your bare ass, I feel
like it's not really,
well, there's no danger there.
(Mori chuckles)
- Right.
- I feel like as a VTuber,
you could cheat the
system somewhere, right?
- Yeah but the model, the
model can just kinda prop.
You have this wonderful ability where-
- Not saying you would do
that, of course, Calli.
- No, no, no, of course not.
- Of course, of course not.
- Nah, it's cool, you
can call it like it is,
I'm fine, I'll take it.
- VTubers have this amazing ability
that when they're not there,
they can still be there.
So I feel like it kind of takes away some
of the magic of sleeptube.
(Joey laughs)
- Yeah, Calli can just
sleep in another room
but she would still be, right.
- Just put on a sleep track,
snoring in the background and it's me,
I'm actually in another room.
I mean, it's scary though,
what if you sleep talk?
you can't risk that.
- Okay, I did leave my mic.
(Mori chuckles)
Just 'cause I didn't wanna-
- You didn't want to take that risk?
- Yeah, I didn't wanna...
I sometimes sleep talk,
I sleep shout as well.
I've been noticing-
- I don't know what kind of
racist shit I'm shouting.
(everyone laughs)
- I recently went on a trip with Chris,
and he said that I woke up at night,
and just shouted and then woke up,
and then just went back
to bed after I shouted.
- What, are you okay?
- I do that, I do that, it
happens, yeah, it happens.
- Really?
- [Garnt] Do you guys snore a lot?
- Just holding back these
Ws in my dream, man.
(Joey and Garnt laughs)
So what can I say?
- Do you guys snore at all?
When you sleep?
- I want to tell you no, Garnt,
but let's be honest, I probably do.
- Yeah, no, you definitely do.
- Okay, shit.
- You definitely do.
- Okay, call me out, all right.
(Garnt chuckles)
- I remember, I think it
was the drifting special,
where someone was snoring
bad on the drifting special.
'Cause like-
- Probably Chris, it must be Chris.
(Garnt chuckles)
- Let's just blame Chris,
anyway, he's not here,
let's blame Chris.
- He can't defend himself, can he?
So.
- You know that you always
have that one friend
who just is the snorer of the group.
And it's always like a time limit.
It's always like a race to get to sleep
before that guy starts snoring, right?
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
- And if there's like multiple snorers,
there's always two level one people.
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
And then there's like
one level 100 person.
You're clearly making
like 90% of the noise.
- What I hate is when there's two people,
who, normally, they're
just level one snorers,
but for some reason when
they sleep together,
they feed into each other, right?
(Joey and Mori laughs)
- It's the resonance of the snores.
(Garnt laughs)
- And it becomes this
horrible cacophony of snoring.
- How'd you know if
you're a snorer though?
That's the question.
- Well, usually a partner tells.
- My significant half tells me.
- Yeah, same.
- Oh yeah.
(Joey chuckles)
I'm just, I'm not recording myself sleep,
what do I know?
- Has anyone ever told you if you snore,
or if you sleeptalk?
- Yeah.
- Or anything like that?
- I went on a trip with Kiara a while ago,
we went to Hokkaido and
she said that I just talked
so much in my sleep.
All the time.
- I do that too.
- She was like, "One
night you sounded sad,
like you were crying then
one night you were laughing,
and it was horrifying."
(Connor laughs)
- Wow.
- Those bars are just
constantly coming, right?
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
- They don't stop, they don't stop.
- I just performed the entirety
of Rap God in my sleep.
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
- You're like an oracle to the Rap God.
- I mean, I guess I could at this point,
I did practice that song a lot.
- It's like she's speaking.
- Oh, oh, can you perform Rap God now?
- Let's see,
♪ Summa-lumma, dooma-lumma,
you assumin' I'm a human ♪
♪ What I gotta do to
get it through to you ♪
♪ I'm superhuman,
innovative and I'm making ♪
That's it.
(Mori chuckles)
- [Connor] Woo.
- I don't have the lyrics in front of me,
that's the problem.
- That was pretty fucking impressive.
- You could've been lying to me there,
and I wouldn't have known.
(Mori laughs)
It doesn't sound like English.
- Oh yeah.
- you could've just said yes.
- Oh yeah, yes.
- We would have believed you.
- Well, I did a rap
endurance stream recently,
where I mastered quote, unquote,
mastered Godzilla, Rap
God and the PokeRap.
And interestingly enough,
the most difficult of all
of them was the PokeRap.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yes.
- How do you pronounce Gyrados?
Like, is it Gehruhdows?
- How do you pronounce it?
- I always say Garuhdowz.
- Garuhdowz.
- I say Garuhdowz.
- See, that's the interesting thing,
is that I went on Google Sensei
who told me that the
pronunciation is different
in American English.
- Really?
- And UK English.
- How do you say it?
- I say Garuhdowz but I
know they say Gehruhdows,
or something like that.
- Yeah.
- Gehruhdows?
- Gehruhdows.
- What the fuck is that?
- I say Garuhdowz.
- Garuhdowz.
- Because in Japanese it's Gyaradosu.
- Yeah I know, bro.
- So I just take it from there.
(Garnt and Mori chuckles)
- I know but I mean, this,
what we're talking about,
I've always got it from the English dub,
which I swear, they say Garuhdowz.
- But the English stuff
is never consistent.
- Yeah but we're also
stupid, we're British.
You have to understand something.
- I remember liking the English dub,
'cause there was another one
that always gets heatly debated, is,
do you say Groudon or do you say Grudon?
- Groudon, I've always
thought it was Groudon.
- Grudon, who the fuck says Grudon?
- Because in the anime they
say it two different times.
- I'm gonna show my
age now, what's Grudon?
(Joey and Mori laughs)
Is that one of the newer Pokemon?
- It's gen three.
- That's from the third gen.
(Garnt laughs)
- The third gen is my
favorite, to be honest.
- It's the same gen that Rayquaza is from.
- You don't know Groudon?
- Ruby, Sapphire, Emerald.
- Oh that's why.
- [Joey] Yeah, Ruby, Sapphire, Emerald.
- I think I-
- And Groudon is the guy on
the front of the Ruby cover,
the big guy, the boss.
- [Garnt] The Godzilla-looking one?
- Yeah.
- What's the blue one called?
- Kyogre.
- [Joey] Yeah, Kygore.
- It's the fucking stingray, right?
(Joey and Mori laughs)
- That's like a whale one.
(hands clapping)
- That's what killed Steve Irwin.
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
- Steve Irwin died from Kyogre, obviously.
(Joey and Mori laughs)
- Oh no.
- Wait, what's his name?
- [Joey] Kyogre.
- Kyogre.
- Yeah, something like that.
K-Y-O-G-
- But I've heard it
being pronounced Keeogre.
- Where did the name come from?
That's just not a memorable
name for me, right?
Like Lugia, that's an
easy name to remember.
Like Zapdos, easy name to remember,
like fucking Ruby, Sapphire passed,
I swear they're just
using Welsh, you know.
It's just-
- Hey, what the fuck?
Don't bring Welsh into this.
- How am I supposed to remember this?
- My man, you do not want
to play the newer ones then.
- Yeah, the newer ones are like-
- Do you like Klefki?
(Mori and Garnt laughs)
- What?
- He is my favorite.
- You know Klefki, right?
- [Mori] Which one is that?
It's the key.
- It's literally the pair of keys.
- It's the pair of keys.
- It's my favorite fucking Pokemon.
- It's like an actual strong
Pokemon for trolling as well.
- [Mori] Wow, that's kinda cool.
- Steel fairy type.
- I feel like they just
dropped a ball on the keyboard
and then just, yeah, okay,
that's the Pokemon name now.
(Mori laughs)
- Garbados, is it, what is it?
- Garbage dose?
(Connor laughs)
- Yes, it's literally a garbage Pokemon.
- Garbados or something?
- Yeah, Garbados, yeah.
- Garbados, it's the garbage Pokemon.
It's just literally garbage.
- [Garnt] A garbage dose.
- It's a trash bag with hands and legs.
- [Garnt] Okay.
(Garnt laughs)
- It's fucking awesome.
- There's an ice cream one too.
- Oh yeah, Vanilluxe.
- They were out of ideas, I see.
- (laughing) What?
- No, not, Vanilla Ice.
(Joey, Connor, Garnt and Mori laughs)
That's a rapper.
- 'Cause I was gonna say, the rapper?
- Isn't that a character from JoJo's?
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
- Is that a motherfucking
JoJo reference, dog?
(Garnt laughs)
Shee.
(Mori chuckles)
- Oh man.
- Oh, so sorry about this.
- See, that's why the
PokeRap is so hard though,
because I'll think that I got through it.
I'll be like, oh yeah, Pigit,
and then the chat will just be full of,
"It's Pidgeot, you dummy."
- [Joey] Pigit.
(Connor, Garnt and Joey laughs)
- Ah, I guess we're starting over again,
great, that's the second to
last name in the PokeRap,
we get to start all the way over.
- How long is the PokeRap?
'Cause I assume you did the
full version with all 151.
- 150, yeah, exactly 150.
- I think it's three minutes
but it feels like 30.
- But didn't they put it
at the end of the episodes?
- Yeah.
- But they only put like a small snippet.
- [Connor] Oh, did they?
- Right.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, it's
only half of them, I think.
The full one is three, four
minutes, something like that.
- Yeah, it's about three to four minutes,
but the hardest part is remembering
how to pronounce everything
without people being like,
"Hey, that ain't right."
- The one line that always stuck with me
during the PokeRap, 'cause
I grew up with that shit,
is, did you perform it properly, Calli?
Where it's like, the last line is, like
Charmeleon and then it's Wartortle.
- Wartortle.
- Yeah, it's like they got a metal singer,
and it's like-
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
It's for, only that part
though, it's like, Charmeleon,
it's like, Wartortle.
- [Mori] Wartortle.
- And I'm like, holy, fuck it,
what happened with Wartortle, dog?
(Garnt laughs)
Jesus Christ.
- We were making fun
of that, actually.
During the stream, my
chat was really excited
about that one part.
- [Joey] Yeah, I didn't know the PokeRap-
- Ladybeard appears out of
nowhere just like (laughing)
(Mori laughs)
- [Mori] I got this.
- I didn't know this rap song
required a fucking death
growl and a metal singer.
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
- Yeah, pretty fun.
- That's a fun song though.
- Fun song.
- Yeah because I remember always trying
to learn the PokeRap when I
was younger and I can't rap.
(Mori laughs)
As we've all established.
- I dunno, man.
- I would pay good money
to watch a childhood Garnt
in his mirror, trying
to sing the Pokemon rap.
I would pay a lot of
money for that, pleasure.
- How many Pokemon are there nowadays?
- 700 and something.
- [Mori] Oh boy.
- Yeah, 750 odd.
- We're gonna reach 1,000,
someday.
- At which point,
do you guys recognize all the Pokemon?
- No.
- [Mori] I've given up.
- I think I know what gen they're from.
- Yeah, I can tell you what
gen they're from but I couldn't
tell you the names.
- But I don't know the names,
yeah, the names are impossible,
the names are like hard mode.
But didn't, who's that YouTuber?
Brian, the guys from Polygon.
- Oh, Brian David Gilbert.
- Yeah, didn't he?
- He made a new PokeRap.
- Where they had all of them.
- It fucking was insane, yeah.
He split up to three separate
parts of the song, basically.
- [Joey] Oh my God.
- And he did every Pokemon,
it was fucking insane.
- [Joey] I wanna see that.
- [Connor] It's very good, it's very good.
- Yeah, I'm curious now.
- And he performed it
live, as well, at a panel.
- [Joey] Wow.
- Which is even more insane.
- [Joey] Holy shit.
- [Man] I told you, the
Pokemon now, is 898.
- So we're boomers, we're even in 800 now.
(Garnt laughs)
- 898.
- Wow, that's a lot.
- I'm curious, you've been streaming now
for over a year now.
What are some of the fun
streams that you've done?
Like the unique ones that
have really stood out
in your mind, I'm curious
'cause I want to know
what kind of streams you jive with most.
- What is your favorite
content that you've produced?
(Joey laughs)
- [Connor] Yeah, content.
(Garnt laughs)
- Content.
- Quote, unquote content, I did
a staring contest, one time.
- Wait, how does that,
wait, what, you did?
- [Mori] Yes.
- How did I not see this?
- [Mori] I was at a friend's
house that I hadn't seen
in a while and I really
couldn't reschedule
hanging out with her.
So I went into the bathroom in the morning
and I took my laptop, I
took my USB microphone,
I pulled myself real
up close to the camera,
and I did a staring contest with everyone,
and it did really well, actually,
there were a lot of people viewing
that stream at once.
- [Joey] Of course it did.
- [Connor] How long did that last?
- About an hour but see
it kind of devolved,
it wasn't entirely, only
me staring at everyone.
In the beginning I started off being,
just kind of sleepy and
quite frankly, a bit rude.
(Garnt and Mori chuckles)
To everyone in chat, I feel
a little bad about that.
But then afterwards we
got onto some fun content,
quote, unquote content.
I actually went and I
found some old copy pastas
to try and read without
cracking a smile on the stream.
And I got through Shrek,
I got through Shrek is-
- Actually, that actually sounds like-
- Oh, Shrek is love, Shrek is life.
- It sounds like a genius
idea, I wanna steal this.
(Connor and Joey chuckles)
- [Mori] Yeah, I recommend it.
- Dude, meme streams always
perform amazing, yeah.
- Yeah, the one that got me though,
I don't know if you guys know this one,
of all the ones to get me,
the one that got me was
Club Penguin Is Kil.
- Oh, yeah (laughing)
- I love that one. -
I love that one.
- [Garnt] What is that one?
- [Mori] Boy, I think
you gotta experience it
for yourself.
- Can you perform it?
- If I could pull it up on my phone,
I'd do it for 'ya, but (laughing).
- [Joey] We need to get it, dog.
- Is it a copypasta, is
it a meme, what is it?
- [Connor] Mm-hmm, copypasta.
- Yeah, it's like a tweet actually.
- Oh, okay, okay.
- Thanks.
- A live reading.
- [Garnt] Yeah, a live
reading of Club Penguin.
- And I'll try not to laugh this time,
'cause it actually wasn't
the copypasta itself
that got me to laugh, it was chat.
- [Joey] Here's the one, right?
- [Connor] Yeah.
(Joey and Connor chuckles)
- Here you go.
- [Cameraman] No explanations.
- Just gotta go into the
void now, we just gotta cut.
Roll this camera on me, camera on me.
- [Joey and Garnt] All right, cut.
- All right, here's my live reading.
(clears throat) Here we go.
This is from Sergeant Arch Dornan
who left a tweet about the Club
Penguin after it shut down.
"Apolgy for bad English.
Where were you when Club Penguin die?
I was at house eating
Dorito when phone ring.
(Connor and Joey chuckles)
Club penguin is kil."
(Garnt, Connor and Joey laughs)
No.
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
Why is it fun, just why?
(Mori laughing)
Just, what is it, about
it, that is so fun?
- It's the Dorito, man.
- It's the Dorito, it's a single Dorito.
- I was eating Dorito.
(Connor, Joey and Garnt laughs)
- But the saddest part
is, the part that got me
to laugh was just everyone
in chat saying no.
(Garnt, Connor and Joey laughs)
- That is what got me,
when that entered the chat.
- Bruno's gonna add
some epic music as you were
reading that or something, man.
(Mori laughs)
- [Joey] Club Penguin Is Kil.
- [Connor] Thank you so much for that.
- Thank you very much for that.
- Dramatic reading, wow.
- [Mori] Absolutely.
I'm go ahead and-
- That's the first copypasta
we've had on Trash Taste.
- Hell yeah.
- [Garnt] Hey.
(Joey and Garnt applauds)
- Hope you guys don't get
in trouble for this content.
- [Connor] No.
- No.
(Mori giggles)
- Should I sneak back the
phone through the void?
- [Garnt] Cut, cut, cut.
- [Mori] Through the void.
Cut, cut, there we go.
- So how do you think
up of ideas for streams?
Because one thing about stream is that.
How often do you stream every week?
- It depends.
I really started to try and
get more into five streams
a week when I was focusing more on music.
But October has been really busy
because it's Halloween,
it's my favorite month,
I am the Grim Reaper.
So I've been doing like
seven to nine a week.
- Jesus.
- Wait, seven to nine?
- Seven to nine streams a week?
- Yes.
- Is that a stream every day?
- Yeah, sometimes two.
- True.
- You know there's seven
days in a week, right?
(Connor, Garnt and Joey laughs)
- That's right.
Well, sometimes I'll clump them together,
because the way I see it,
is if I can get one day off
where I don't have to worry
about anything, that's great.
But if I can do two
streams at once in a day,
it's like I can get all of it done.
- Wait, wait and you're doing
music on top of this as well?
- Yeah.
- What the fuck, Calli?
(Mori laughs)
- Built different.
- Yeah, it's fun.
Well, I mean, I like
streaming a lot, it's great.
But my passion at the end
of all of it, is music,
and I can't resist doing
that, working on music.
- How'd you think up of nine
different streams a week.
Does it, do you, sometimes, is it easy?
Do you have an idea that you fall back on,
or does it get tiring having
to think up of variety streams?
Different things you can do.
- 'Cause I think Garnt can only think
of nine videos a year, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, I was gonna say, yeah.
- Garnt's like, "shit, fate, fate, fate."
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
- Fuck, how many Fate videos can I make?
(Garnt, Joey and Mori laughs)
- Interestingly enough,
it's a situation where I
keep thinking of things
that I want to stream in that week,
and then I ended up
clogging up my schedule.
So there are just a lot of
games that I want to play.
There was a situation
where I ordered the WiiU
four different times, finally got it.
- Wait, what?
- Yeah, so let me explain,
let me explain how this went down.
So I ordered a WiiU
while I was in America,
so that I could have it shipped,
and then I could take it back with me
to Japan so that I could play EarthBound
because I've been really trying
to do an EarthBound playthrough on stream.
And so I got that but it
arrived too late in America,
I was already in Japan.
So then I ordered one to come
to Japan, a Japanese one.
I thought you could change the language
to English, you cannot.
- No.
- Nope.
- So that didn't work out.
Everything I read on the
internet was a lie about that.
So I gave it to a friend and
then after that I ordered one
on eBay from America.
They tried to deliver it to my house,
after one failed delivery
attempt, sent it back to America.
So finally, finally I got one off
of Amazon that they were
willing to ship to Japan,
and it arrived.
And finally I have a fucking WiiU.
(Garnt laughs)
So I can-
- Four WiiUs later.
- [Joey] Four WiiUs later.
- Four WiiUs later, yeah,
but that's the question.
There are too many
things that I want to do.
- I feel you, I feel you.
- I feel you.
- For EarthBound on the stream,
oh, but I got to finish
playing Doom Eternal.
Oh but there's this other
game that I want to play,
wait a minute, we just
got permission for this,
I want to stream this before
anyone else, kind of thing.
Two different people want
to do a collaboration,
well, I always love doing collabs
with people that reach out
to me, so let's do it.
Everyone's been asking
for a Minecraft stream,
let's play Minecraft.
I haven't done a chatting
stream in a while,
want to let everyone know what's going on.
I want to talk about my new
song that just came out.
I mean, I haven't done an
ASMR stream in a while,
it's just all these ideas
come to me and I'm like-
- Man, I wish I could be
this full of ideas, man.
(Garnt laughs)
- I mean, it's a bit of a
stress and I really should learn
to spread things out more often.
I just get real excited about,
I have an idea, let's do it now, yeah.
- Well, it sounds like you've
gone from three part-time jobs
to working three part-time
jobs in one job, so.
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah, it does feel like
that when you're on charge
of your own schedule, it gets
to be like that sometimes.
- I saw that you were doing
a convention appearance.
- [Mori] Yeah.
- Is it almost strange doing
it virtually as opposed to IRL?
- That's a good question.
It does feel a little unreal sometimes,
but then once I see like all
the fans gathered together,
it all starts to settle and I'm like,
"Oh man, this is a real thing,
wow, people really like us."
And I think once we started,
for example, doing the fan expo panels,
that was when I kind of started to realize
really, how many fans we have
and it made it all super real
for me, so that was cool.
- Do you ever feel a bit sad
that you can never interact
with them directly?
'Cause to us that's like
a big part of us going
to conventions, right?
Do you-
- Yeah, I mean, I hope that there's a day
where that kind of thing can happen.
I mean, I have a friend I've talked about
on the stream before, Milky Queen,
she does things like that.
Going to conventions and
can actually meet full body
in front of a green screen
in front of the fans.
- Oh nice.
- And they can touch the
screen and high five her,
and stuff like that.
And that's something I'd love to do.
I don't really know if
that's something that Holo
can accomplish right now,
but I think it would
be amazing, personally.
- Technology these days, man.
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
- Everyone get in VR
with the haptic suits.
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah.
- [Mori] Yeah, that's right.
We're actually gonna-
- What is it called now?
The metaverse or whatever?
Is that what Facebook are trying
to develop or something?
- Oh, they have a name for it.
Oh geez.
- Basically Facebook just make VTubers,
'cause that will make the
interest just 10 times more.
- Oh for sure.
Yeah, well, interestingly enough,
we did do a VR stream, myself
and all of the Mythrils,
we did a, for our anniversary,
we all got into VR chat
and we actually all bought
the suits to track our
movements and stuff like that.
- Oh wow.
- We went as small versions of ourselves.
- I saw this, yeah, I did see it, yeah.
- That was so fun and it just made me want
to meet with the others even more,
so that we can really,
fully debut, someday in 3D.
- Is it weird wearing
a full tracking suit?
- What is the full tracking suit?
Is it the one like the mo-cap?
Is it the actual mo-cap suits?
Or is it the one where you, it's on the-
- I think it's two on the
hands, two on the feet,
and then one on your waist.
- Yeah, you track your waste movements.
I had a little too much
fun with that though
with all the tracking.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
I was moving around,
maybe a little too much,
probably could have dialed it back a bit,
but I was so excited to be in a 3D space,
able to move with my friends.
- Yeah, VR is definitely
like that the first time.
You're like, "Holy shit."
And then you've realized
that you're sweating a lot
and then you've burned 10,000 calories
because you were having so much fun.
(Garnt laughs)
Have you played this
game called Gorilla Tag?
(Connor chuckles)
- [Garnt] No.
- [Mori] What?
(Garnt chuckles)
- On the topic of VR,
so Connor had his house
warming party the other day,
and Chris was there
and seeing Chris try VR
for the first time was a
fucking site to behold.
- We gave Chris a few drinks.
(Garnt laughs)
And I was like-
- A few.
- I was like, Chris, you
should try playing Superhot.
(Joey laughs)
- [Mori] Superhot, oh no.
- And Chris was like-
- I'm so upset I missed out on that.
- Dude, he was rolling on the
floor, doing jumps and shit,
like James Bond in my bedroom.
(Garnt laughs)
Smacking the walls, nearly
broke all my JoJo posters.
- First thing I see,
I walk in and Chris is
fucking punching something.
He punches a JoJo poster right there.
- He nearly broke it.
(Mori laughs)
Just full on punching in VR.
I'm like, Chris, it's okay, it's okay.
(Joey and Garnt laughs)
Guy nearly destroyed my apartment.
He was like, what is this?
It's shit, it's shit, he
put it on, he loved it.
(Garnt laughs)
It's classic Chris.
- Well, that's VR, right.
I've tried to talk so many people into VR
and they're just like,
nah, I don't get it,
it's probably not for me.
It's definitely one of those things
that you just have to try.
And it's like, once you try
it, then you fully understand.
You could give a fucking
dissertation on why VR is awesome,
and you probably couldn't get-
- I mean, the thing about VR
is that I can only play VR
for a certain amount of time
before it just feels less casual.
I don't know.
I sweat a lot in VR.
- You gotta play Gorilla Tag,
that's where the real-
- What's Gorilla Tag?
- Yeah, how do you play it?
- It's exactly what it sounds like.
You're gorillas and you tag each other.
(Joey laughs)
- [Mori] Oh boy.
- I did it on stream, right,
I thought it would just be chasing people.
It turns out it's just 10 year olds,
just playing as gorillas.
- [Garnt] What do you mean?
- It's all 10 year olds.
I joined a lobby and 10
year olds were swearing
and saying horrible things.
- [Mori] Ah, that sounds about right.
- And I was like-
- So it's just XBox live all over again.
(Mori laughs)
- If you want Xbox, go and
play Gorilla Tag, right.
Because what happens is, the way you-
- Connor gets to relive his childhood,
that's why he loved it so much.
(all laughing)
- No, no.
I did not like this.
I realized the power you have as a kid
is unobtainable as an adult.
Those kids could say and do anything.
I can't say that shit back
to them, it's so unfair.
The kids can say whatever
they want and it's like-
- What do you mean it's unfair?
- I want to be able to call
that kid a little shit.
- Well, why can't you call
that kid a little shit?
- I'm on stream, I can't say
it, off stream I'll say it.
(Connor and Joey laughs)
Come here, you little shit.
- [Mori] Chat will do it for
you, chat will do it for you.
- Get over here.
- [Mori] On your behalf.
- Yeah, yeah, please come in and just-
- What were they saying to you?
- They were saying words that
you cannot say on stream.
Some-
- Were you streaming?
- And I was streaming.
There's a clip of me, I go
in a world, I joined it,
and one of the kids was saying
the word that you cannot say.
- Yeah.
- And I was like, all
right then, can I go away?
And then just left the
world 'cause he was,
this 10 year old kid was screaming it,
but it's really fun, right?
So you do this, you have the controllers,
and they act as your-
- It sounds like a bunch of apes in there.
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
- So you have two of the
VR controllers, right?
- Yeah.
- And those are your legs and your arms,
so when you want to move you
to have jump with the legs.
- Oh okay, yeah.
- To push off them.
And people are insane,
these kids are insane.
They're like flying across
the map and I can barely move.
I really felt like a boomer.
(Garnt, Mori and Joey laughs)
You should play Gorilla Tag.
- Oh, sure.
- How long do you play VR for though?
How long did you stream for?
Three hours, four hours, maybe.
- Three hours?
Did you not get sweaty?
- Extremely so.
- Okay, that's what puts me off VR.
It's like I stream, I play
for now, I get really sweaty,
and then you don't take the VR set off,
you fucking peel it off
at that point, right?
It just doesn't feel good.
- At least the Index has
the removable face thing.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So you can clean it, so I
didn't feel too disgusted by it.
- So you're just cycling
through the foam parts.
- I'm cleaning it a lot.
- [Garnt] Okay.
- Wait, which headset are you using?
- I'm using the Valve Index,
yeah, it's super good.
- I hate wires though.
- [Garnt] I hate that as well.
- The wires are the only
thing that take you out of it,
I feel like.
- Yeah, I feel like, once
it gets to wireless headsets
that are high quality, then I would get
more invested into VR.
- Oh, Oculus 2, right?
It's the wireless one, right?
- Yeah, I think the specs aren't as good
as the Index though, but I mean,
it's pretty good from
what I've heard though.
- I haven't streamed on my Oculus 2 yet,
but I bought it just because
I heard that there's no wires.
I'm like, good, that's great.
- The Index is super easy to use.
- Was that the first
time you had tried VR,
or had you tried VR before your stream?
- Actually, to be honest,
I kind of wasn't interested
at all in it, but Amelia's
like the tech wizard
in Myth and she was just kinda like,
"Hey, what if we did a big VR
collab for our anniversary?"
And all of us were like, okay, but how?
And she's like, no, it's super easy.
And she told us everything
we needed to buy.
- That sounds like a technical nightmare.
- [Connor] Gamer god.
- My God. Oh my God.
Imagine trying to schedule
that and sort that shit out.
I go through enough technical issues,
just streaming on my PC.
- [Joey] On my own.
- On my own.
Let alone doing a cross
continental VR stream.
- [Joey] Oh my God.
- With motion capture.
- She worked really hard.
- I'm curious, is there
anything with being
a VTuber over the past
year that you've learned
is annoyingly difficult that other people
would just never consider?
- Oh, let me think, this is a tough one.
One sec.
- [Connor] No worries, no worries.
- You gotta think 'cause
there are a lot of things
that looks fun.
- 'Cause I feel like I don't
appreciate how difficult
it can be sometimes.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I just look at them and I just think,
"Oh wow, you guys don't have
to worry about how you look,
you can just change the model,
it's great, I'm so jealous."
- I mean, there's a lot of stuff,
behind the scenes that we have to do,
is the thing.
A lot of people,
they see us for maybe two, three hours,
if you stream for a short amount of time,
if you do like an endurance
stream, eight hours, sure.
But here's the thing though,
when we press go live,
and after we're done, stop the stream,
immediately what I do is
I go sit on the couch,
and I start making thumbnails.
- [Connor] God.
- I make a bunch of
thumbnails for the week,
then I have to make the schedule,
which last time, took me
about an hour and a half.
- So do you make the thumbnails yourself?
- [Mori] Yes.
- Oh my God.
- I think most VTubers do, right?
- What?
- [Garnt] Why?
(Garnt laughs)
- That's the one thing I'm so impressed
with VTubers is that they always
have unique thumbnails for everything.
And I'm like, I didn't
realize how grateful I am
that Twitch, you don't have to do that.
- Yeah, how did you learn how to do that?
Because like not to be
like a dumb question,
but thumbnails are like a very fine art
that a lot of YouTubers
learn as they go along.
I mean, I didn't know how
to make good thumbnails
until a year or two after I
started doing it properly.
- Well, there's people on the platform
that have been on for like 10 years
that still don't know
how to make those well.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- I mean, it's something
that you just kind of learn along the way,
because for me, I had no idea.
My thumbnail game was real weak before,
but I had to get good at it.
And I started kind of seeing
what others did as well,
and not completely taking
everything that everyone did,
but little things here
and there that I had,
I noticed and be like, ah,
I should do a stroke layer
on this text like this,
and it'll look a lot better
and a drop shadow here,
and that kind of stuff.
And it's all just fine little things,
you'd never really think super hard about,
but they do make a difference.
- Yeah, exactly.
How long do you guys
spend on your thumbnails?
- I try to do it as little as possible.
I try and outsource it as much as I can.
(Joey laughs)
- See this guy's working smart.
I think I spend maybe
like, max, 30 minutes.
I'm quite short when it
comes to thumbnails, yeah.
- I feel like if you have the capacity
to pay someone else to do something,
you should pay someone
else to do something.
(Joey snickers)
(Mori laughs)
- [Garnt] No but like-
- It's work it's business, I
want more time to do my stuff.
- Not exactly but-
- For some people they value
the creative aspect.
- Some privilege, I know.
Shut up, shut up.
(Chad laughs)
See Chad laughing at me.
(Mori and Garnt laughs)
- Yeah, I mean, the thing
is, for example, for VTubers,
there are so many of them
that want to be in control
of their own thumbnails, that
it becomes a creativity thing.
- I feel like thumbnails are
important because with you,
you've got an artist doing
a lot of your thumbnails.
And aside from that, it's
like taking the perfect shot
on scene or something.
Whereas my thumbnails can take up to like,
some thumbnails, I can
outsource, some I can't
because even I don't
know how to market some
of my videos, right?
I don't know, for me, when
you upload twice a week,
or recently once a month,
you need to make that
fucking thumbnail count, man.
- That's why twice a
week can double my views.
- No, sorry, twice a month, twice a month.
Once every two weeks.
You need to make those thumbnails count,
with Trash Taste it's just easy.
If one thumbnail doesn't
hit, you got next week.
With me, I'm just like, "If
this thumbnail doesn't hit,
I gotta wait a fucking month, man."
(Mori laughs)
That shit hurts.
- Have you thought about,
perhaps, uploading more often.
(Mori and Garnt laughs)
- Well, that means making content
that's faster to make.
- The pressure.
- Yeah, yeah.
- There's less pressure
on making that perfect
thumbnail, all right.
- Joey, I am making as much
content as I possibly can,
Joey, please, okay.
- I mean, I think another
thing that people also
don't realize is, one big
factor, is just simply
the energy it takes to
be you all the time.
When I'm putting up a
schedule for a new stream,
I've got to put in a
description that I think,
kind of, either matches
or is this too much?
Am I saying too many
things in the description?
You overthink a lot in this job.
Am I going to put out a tweet
that says a lot of things?
Or one sentence, a couple words?
You have to always think
about this kind of stuff.
And scheduling meetings as
well, that's another big thing.
- It's interesting that you
mentioned about description
and tags, I guess and
the tweet and everything,
'cause I think over the six years,
what I've learned is
that I just don't care
about any of that now.
(Mori and Joey chuckles)
Calli, do you care about
your description anymore?
- No.
- I used to care, right.
And then I found out
that all the big channels
just don't do any of that.
They don't put anything in the tags.
- I think my experience,
there's two things that matters,
title, thumbnail.
- [Connor] It's literally that.
- That's literally the
only real thing you need
to worry about, tags and stuff
and descriptions and stuff,
it doesn't help as much anymore.
And I know this now
because, have you guys gone
through this issue recently
with YouTube, right?
Where you search for a for
a certain video, right?
And then the first three
searches are pertaining
to that search.
And then for some reason
after about five searches,
it just goes back to your
recommendations just nowadays.
I'm just like, what is the point
of the search function anymore?
If the first five videos,
aren't what I'm searching for,
then I'm just fucked.
- Or it's like, "The
viewers of your channel
also viewed this."
It's like, I don't care.
(Mori laughs)
That's not what I searched for.
- That's literally not
what I searched for.
It's gone to the point where,
back when YouTube started,
it's just like, okay,
I subscribe to the
channels I want to watch,
YouTube's like, "No, no, no, no,
you don't want to watch these channels."
"You want to watch these channels."
And I'm like, okay, maybe I
won't get recommendations.
Now, it's just like, I want to
search for a specific video,
and YouTube is like, "No, no, no, no, no."
- [Joey] "No, you don't."
- "You don't want to search for that."
- Yes, because of the algorithm.
- "You want to watch these videos."
- The ones that annoy me the
most is after the fifth search.
It's like, "Here's a
new video from someone
you're subscribed to."
I'm like, "What is the
point of the subscriptions?"
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
I can check that, there was
an entire page for that.
- What is the point of pages now?
'Cause all pages are just gonna become
the same page eventually, right.
- Exactly, so annoying.
- What is the point of the search bar?
So yeah, to me descriptions
and tags don't mean
as much anymore.
It's all about title,
thumbnail, viewer retention,
because it's all recommendations,
we all bow down to the almighty algorithm.
And that's unfortunately what you gotta do
to be a YouTuber nowadays.
- [Joey] Yeah, pretty much.
- And I mean, I guess it does
make sense that it should be,
what you say and what you create,
and not necessarily what you're typing
into the description, right?
I mean, every time that
I see, for example,
some of my gem mates, they
just throw up a schedule,
nothing in the descriptions and I'm like,
"Wow, what a bunch of Chads."
(Garnt laughs)
It doesn't matter but
I mean, I don't know.
I guess I'm still,
there's still some things
I'm figuring out, day by day.
I've gotten a lot better
than I was in the past.
And I feel good about that, so
day by day though, you can
always learn new stuff,
especially in this job.
- I feel you've done a
shit load in just a year.
(Mori laughs)
- Considering what you've
learnt in this year
and what you've done in this
year, it's actually insane,
compared to, I look back
on some of the years
I've had on YouTube and I'm just like,
"I'm doing fucking nothing."
- How do you mainly, would
you say, you learn things
on streaming and YouTube?
Do you do learn from other gem mates,
or do you learn from outside of hololive,
or do you learn all on yourself?
I'm curious where you kind
of pick up this stuff.
- A lot of times it's
like a feeling that I get,
like after I'm done with a stream,
I can feel whether it was bad or good.
- [Connor] Oh no, I agree, I agree.
- I can feel what I did wrong.
This technically wasn't good,
these people were angry
about this, et cetera.
And it's all in my mind.
And I'm very receptive to criticism,
but something that I also learned is
that not every criticism that you get
that is framed politely
is necessarily correct.
- [Connor] True.
- That's a lie that we tell ourselves,
so that we don't come
off as butthurt babies.
But the truth of the matter is,
you don't need to 100%
take every single critique that you get
from every anonymous
person on the internet
even if it's framed nicely,
you need to be able to
discern what is actually going
to help you and what isn't.
But one thing that you
shouldn't do is lash out.
I would say that's a given.
- Never feed the trolls
'cause it never ends up well.
- There are people that get excited
when I talk about them and
the bad things they say.
And the thing that you do
is you don't give it to them
and you just ignore.
- I mean, yeah, it's rule number
one, don't feed the trolls.
- That was another thing I had to learn
as well along the way.
- When you started off,
did you get a lot of advice
from, maybe, your fellow gem mates?
Or over itself, about what to do in terms
of how to handle your content
and just general advice
to be a content creator in general
was it all just trial by fire?
- I'm going to be honest with you.
We really were just
kinda, they just said go.
And I think that part of that is,
because in the process of selecting us,
they've made sure that we
would be okay with that
because all of us that
have gone through it,
have not, there hasn't
been like a huge disaster
or anything like that with
us in terms of streaming.
Everyone has a good handle on themselves.
And I think you got to
give it to, I guess,
who chose us for that, specifically.
They did choose people that have a handle
on how to do things.
However, that isn't to say
that we were all experienced
streamers in the beginning.
'Cause that's definitely not the case,
I had barely streamed in my entire life,
I was mostly making music in the shadows.
- [Connor] Quite different.
- Extremely different.
But somehow they knew that I'd be able
to handle it, somehow.
And you learn a lot of
things along the way,
but in the beginning we
all did have the ability
to get through that starting line,
but we didn't get a lot of advice,
I will be honest about that.
- I think one of the biggest
things you have to learn,
which a lot of people,
maybe, might not consider,
is the technical side of things
because with a YouTube video,
if something technical
happens on set or something,
some things you could
kind of save and post
there is no getting around
technical issues on stream.
- Exactly.
- And I feel like the only
way you've really learned
is when it happens on
stream and you're just like,
"well, I guess I just have to learn not
to do that again, right?"
- Stuff breaks a lot as
well, it's normal, right?
Yeah, damn, so you mainly
did a lot of it on your own,
you learned everything, wow.
So when you started off,
there was nobody who was like,
"Hey, by the way, people might
just say bad things about you
for no reason, that might just happen,
just like, it's gonna happen."
No one told you?
- There was a question that I will say,
because it's kind of obvious
that they would ask us this.
People are going to say mean
things about you and hate you,
are you okay with that?
And obviously all of us got in.
(Garnt laughs)
We all said yes, but I recall
that my answer, specifically,
was, well, I've dealt with that,
with my music before all of this.
I did indeed have people
that would come around
and do a little bit of
trolling, so to speak.
And I felt like I had
dealt with them pretty well
by just not saying anything.
- [Connor] 100%.
- And I feel like,
I thought to myself, that I should be fine
when I enter holo and it's been fine.
So that's okay for me.
Everyone's experience though is different,
I would say, so.
- Yeah, I think as well,
there is the added,
very scary aspect of it being,
again, this is just my
perception of being a VTuber,
everyone is just trying to find out
as much personal information
about you as possible.
Whereas everyone can just
see that I'm a teenager now
and I'm-
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
I feel like older people are definitely,
big people, trying to get
our personal information,
but I don't feel like it's intense.
At least I don't see it,
maybe, I'm just too lazy,
I'm not looking, but-
- Or you've already shown everything
there is too offer.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(Connor chuckles)
- 'Cause one thing I've
always been curious about is,
do you feel pressure to have to keep,
say a certain image of yourself
for your audience or just the
general perception of VTubers?
Because we obviously keep a certain image,
but I feel like it's
nothing on the same level
as what VTubers have to go through.
- [Connor] Right.
- It's rough because I feel
one thing that I learned is,
at the end of the day,
I've got maybe about 80%
of a fanbase that really, really want me
to be 100% just myself.
I see them in the comments
all the time saying,
you're doing great Calli,
just, loosen up a little bit.
In the beginning, right, for example,
you guys saw when I first came here,
I was trying to be something
that I wasn't, for real.
(Garnt laughs)
- I remember it was quite strange
but, I mean, it turned out good.
- No, it was a good episode, yeah.
- All a part of my
development, you know and that-
- We literally saw the development
on the two hour podcast.
- Exactly, exactly.
And so, for those people saying,
just be yourself, Calli,
I gotta say thank you,
because it was because
of comments like that,
that I realized, "Hey, maybe it's okay
for me to loosen up a little bit, relax."
People want to see who I am
for who I am and that's great.
But of course you're gonna get
a small but loud minority of people
that wants you to be a certain way
and you just gotta deal with it.
I personally have found, I think,
a happy medium where
I'm still being myself,
but I'm not, going into territory
that would make others
angry, like viciously angry.
- [Connor] Yeah, of course, of course.
- 'Cause I feel when comments
tell you to be yourself,
it's kind of like a trap.
(Connor laughs)
Because they want you to be
yourself but not yourself
that they don't like.
- What is myself to you?
Exactly.
- Just like the worst person.
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah, you want me to
be myself but I'm trash.
- Oh fuck, go back.
- Go back, go back.
- Wait a minute, not like that.
- I think when they say you
should just be yourself,
what they actually mean is be yourself,
but the version that I like.
- Yeah, exactly, right?
(Garnt chuckles)
- Yeah, that's exactly it, yeah.
But I try to look at
it in a positive light,
and just do the best that
I can to be the best me,
and just stay positive.
I've found that negativity
tripped me up a lot
in the beginning.
And I've been trying to smile through
even the difficult times.
And it sounds cheesy, it's
anime as hell, I get it.
(Garnt chuckles)
But it's the truth.
- Smile through the tears,
just smile through the tears.
- Smile through the tears.
- Smile through the ending
song, it's all right.
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
I like it.
- Yeah, yeah, definitely.
But I feel a positive outlook is good
and necessary if you
want to keep doing this
for a long time.
And so I feel like things
have gone pretty well,
and all I can keep doing
is being the best me,
because at the end of
the day, no matter what,
someone's going to be
angry at you for something.
And if people are
constantly going to be like,
"Be this way, be this way."
And constantly upset at
the choices that you make,
why not make the choice
that you want to make
and just deal with it from there?
- Yeah, it's nice 'cause when
we met you on the podcast,
I didn't really know
of your streams at all.
I'd seen it a little
bit and definitely now,
even throughout the year, when I check in,
it seems like every single
time I've watched your streams,
you just seem more
comfortable and more chill.
And it's really cool to see.
- I'm better at Doom, I'm
better at Doom Eternal.
(Garnt laughs)
- And you're better at Doom, let's go.
- I'm better at Doom.
(Mori, Garnt and Connor laughs)
I think you got further than
me in Jump King as well.
- I've been grinding on
that Jump King struggle.
- That is painful absolutely painful.
Have you played Jump King?
- No, I've been trying to get
a bunch of people to race it
with me though.
'Cause I really want to play.
- [Mori] Oh it's hard.
- [Garnt] What's Jump King?
- [Mori] I recommend it.
- You don't want to know Jump King is.
- Yes, you do.
- Oh we should race it together on stream.
- I've only played like two hours of it,
so I'm down to play.
- It's an endurance game.
- Yeah, yeah, we can-
- No, one's answered my question yet.
- [Connor] You don't deserve to know.
- You can't handle the truth.
- You wouldn't know how to handle it.
- I'm like, "What is Jump King?
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, we
should do it together.
Oh, you've done it, oh, you've done it,
yeah I've got to as well."
- Garnt take a wild guess
what you do in Jump King.
- You're a king and you jump.
- You jump.
(Mori and Garnt laughs)
You jump up Garnt.
- Before I agreed to this,
I could be agreeing to
a fucking suicide pact
for all I know.
Are we jumping off a cliff?
- [Connor] Basically.
- Is that what Jump King is?
- It's just code.
(Joey and Garnt laughs)
- [Mori] Oh, you wish.
- We're doing the Jump King.
- Let's not explain what
Jump King is to Garnt.
- [Mori] All right, next time.
- Honestly, best way to
experience it, in my opinion,
just go in blind 'cause
that's what happened to me.
- What's the game with the pickax and the-
- [Garnt] No, no, no.
- Getting Over It.
- [Mori] Getting Over It,
Getting Over It.
- Yeah, imagine Getting
Over It with jumping.
(Mori and Cameraman laughs)
That's literally it.
- [Joey] Yeah, have you
played Getting Over It?
- No.
- Bennett Foddy's Getting Over It.
- You know what Getting Over It is.
- It's the naked guy in the pod.
- He's in a pod.
- You have to use the
pickax to get to the top
of the mountain.
- Oh yeah I know that one.
- Imagine but jumping.
- Imagine that but jumping, yeah.
- Okay.
- And you're a king.
- And I like the art more.
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
- And you can just fall to the bottom.
- And it's got really
good pixel art as well.
- Okay, the art is amazing.
- [Mori] Yeah, I love it.
- But it is
rage inducing.
- It's doodle jump,
it's basically doodle jump.
- It's doodle jump.
- But with a king.
- With Getting over it.
- Exactly.
- Okay, okay.
- It is rough, it is very difficult,
but the way that I've gotten around it,
is I've started jumping into voice chat
with the hololive English.
- Is that a pun?
(Mori, Garnt and Chad laughs)
- I just got that.
- [Connor] That wasn't a pun, my God.
- Okay, I was just-
(Ganrt and Mori laughs)
- I just want to know
if you did that on purpose.
- Jumping, wink, wink.
- We're accepting new
applicants for Trash Taste.
(Joey applauds)
- But I've been sitting in
voice chat, just waiting,
I've just been waiting for
other members to jump in,
and have a little chat with me.
And the time flew by,
I got into chat and two
of the other members,
IRyS and Bae just jumped into voice chat.
And we just talked about
anime the whole time
that I was suffering, trying
to climb this building,
and eight hours just
flew by, it was amazing.
- [Connor] Wow.
- Hell yeah.
- Oh yeah, I mean, I guess without it,
it's like you're basically in
solitary confinement, right?
- [Mori] Yeah, exactly.
(Joey chuckles)
- Sounds horrible.
- It's a horrible race.
- That's why I want to race it, right.
So I can distract myself by
talking shit to other people.
- So what is the point of Jump King?
Is there an ending?
- Jump to the top.
- There's a super hot babe
at the top.
- Jump to the top.
- Save the princess.
- There's a cute lady.
- [Garnt] Okay, okay.
- A hot lady.
- Yeah, a smoking hot babe.
- Smoking hot babe.
- That's it.
- Thank you for explaining
to me what Jump King is,
I have a general idea now.
(Mori laughs)
I would like to try streaming that.
- Give it a shot.
(Garnt laughs)
See how far you get.
- That's a lie,
don't get my hopes up like that, Garnt.
(Joey and Garnt laughs)
- I want to see all of
you race in Jump King.
- Yeah we should.
- You could be the MC.
- All right, gotcha, I'll
narrate the whole thing.
- So is it like Get Over It?
Where it's easy to reach
or where it's really hard
to reach the end in one playthrough or-
- Yeah and it's really easy
to just drop down.
- Fall to the bottom.
- And fall to the bottom.
- Yeah, you could have been
playing for five hours,
and you've made it so many levels up,
and then just one wrong fall leads
to a chain of more wrong
falls that put you down
at the very first stage.
- And then you get tilted and
then you start just throwing.
- You can't remember how
to jump into certain places
that you were jumping before, yeah.
- You just run into a
blind rage after a while.
- Cool, love it, can't wait.
- Yeah, it's great fun.
(Garnt laughs)
- It's so fun.
- It's really going to test
your monk mode skills, for sure.
(Garnt laughs)
- Oh my God.
- So what's your favorite
type of content to make then?
Is it playing games or is it
interacting with the chat?
- Ah, let's see, interestingly enough,
I felt like my interaction
skills with chat
were kind of non-existent
in the beginning.
To be completely honest it's
'cause I was a big Ol' baby.
Especially towards the beginning.
- Big Ol' baby.
- Especially playing games.
- That must be terrifying, right?
- Knowing that I'm bad at video games,
I was really kind of
scared to check the chat,
because I didn't want to lose,
energy and momentum by seeing
someone say, "Hey, you suck."
Because while I'm aware I'm
not very good at video games,
it's like seeing everyone telling you how
to do a certain thing.
Even if I can hold back a
reaction or a snarky remark,
it does bring down the energy a bit,
and I want to stay high energy.
so it's something I had to learn to do
to really kind of put up a wall
between people leaving funny comments,
or just general feedback,
and people screaming at you in all caps,
that you should be using
a pickax to break stones
instead of a shovel, which is-
- [Connor] That's true, that is true.
- I will say that is a
good piece of advice,
and I appreciate it as advice
and I appreciate it as advice.
- That's a good piece of life advice.
(Joey and Garnt giggle)
- [Mori] When it's not in all caps.
- The same thing applies in real life.
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
- That is true.
I'm more likely to listen
to it if it's phrased,
not in all caps though.
That's a general, just a good
idea for chat, I would say.
In general, I don't really
actually care too much
about back seating.
It's when it gets to be
everyone and super aggressive
that my energy begins to fall.
So I had to kind of learn to
like, "Hey Calli, get over it."
Just try and turn your vision
into a way that it can
just pick out comments,
and chat that aren't entirely aggressive,
and you keep the stream going.
And so I do like interacting
with chat these days.
Chat can be funny, they have some jokes,
you guys have jokes out there, I will say.
And they really do kind
of brighten up my day,
so it's been worth it in the end,
but I'd say that my favorite
kinds of streams to do,
probably variety streams.
Though they do take the most preparation.
Recently, I've been trying
to do a Kiowa stream.
So English learning by speaking
simple and slow English
for anyone really not
only Japanese viewers,
but people around the world
who maybe have English
as a second language.
That takes a lot of preparation.
- Oh, when you said English learning,
I was like you learning English?
(Mori and Garnt laughs)
I think you've already got that down.
(Garnt laughs)
Guys, I'm going to do an
English learning stream today.
- Yeah, gonna do my best.
- English learning stream,
next week we're gonna perform the PokeRap.
- To be fair, you should do
a Duolingo English speed run.
See how good you are at
English, see if you could do it.
- [Mori] That's a good idea.
- I feel like I would be
way worse than I think
I have any right to be
at English in Duolingo.
- I feel like, I don't know,
that's an interesting stream actually.
Seeing if you are as fluent in English,
as something like Duolingo thinks you are.
- What's the main language then?
That you have the application set on
if you're learning English?
Can it be English again?
(Garnt chuckles)
- [Connor] I guess so.
- That's a good question.
(Garnt, Mori and Joey laughs)
- [Joey] I can't it explain it too then.
- I don't think Duolingo has
ever thought about that before.
- Yeah, I guess so.
- This is gonna so bad.
So what do I'm learning Japanese, right?
And they're like, oh
yeah, it's like a pronoun,
and I was like, yeah, for
the first time I hear it.
I was like, what is that again?
(Joey laughs)
I was like-
- What's a pronoun?
- No, I know but you
know when you hear it,
you're like, I haven't heard that in,
when you got the different types
of verbs and nouns, you're
like, wait, hold on,
let me refresh my memory of
what that is again, hold up.
It's been like five years, you know.
- I'm trying to remember
what a pronoun is.
(Joey laughs)
- 'Cause they obviously think
when the Japanese teacher
is teaching me Japanese, they're like,
oh, you know this stuff, it's English.
It's fluent, you speak it, right?
And it's like, yeah, yeah,
I remember that stuff,
I remember fluently.
- I don't think that works when it comes
to learning languages
though, to me at least.
When I hear something is a pronoun,
I don't think I remember what,
well, as we've just established,
we don't know what a fucking
pronoun is in our own language.
(Mori chuckles)
How the fuck are we going to
learn that in another language?
- That's why it's so
embarrassing when I'm there
in front of the teacher who is Japanese,
and she's like, oh, it's
just like this thing,
and I'm like, yeah.
(Garnt laughs)
Yeah.
- [Mori] I know what that is.
- Yeah, exactly, right?
I'm like, totally, I know what that is.
(Joey laughs)
Yeah, okay.
- I know what an adjective is.
(Joey and Connor laughs)
- Adjective and noun
and verbs are the ones
that you should know and then
anything else, I'm like, yeah.
- A pronoun.
- I know pronouns, yeah.
- Proverbs.
- Fuck but I don't know what that is.
I mean, I know that it exists
but if you asked me right now.
- I know it exists but
I don't know what it is.
- This is bad, right?
I should know this, this is my language.
- Tell me how to use a semi-colon.
(Garnt laughs)
(Mori laughs)
I don't know if you just heard
the groan across this office
that we just had.
- I will use a semi-colon,
I don't think I'm remotely correct.
But I will throw one in
there just for good measure.
- I kind of use it like
using a comma and a full stop
at the same time, kind of sentence.
- You actually know the way that I think
I learned how to use a semi-colon?
It's the Lonely Island song, Semi Colon.
(Joey laughs)
It's a great example.
- Oh that's right, I remember that.
- I was like, oh, that's
the first time I've seen
the explanation of
semi-colon where I'm like,
that makes sense now, that makes sense.
- I dunno, I just feel like
we're the era of auto-corrects,
and shit like that.
We just pay way less attention to it.
I've just started using
apostrophes in places
where apostrophes don't need to be used,
but it just looks right.
And I know it's wrong sometimes.
- Well, it's like with
languages like Japanese,
sometimes, some people, some
of the younger generation
don't know how to write the Kanji,
'cause they're typing it all the time.
And that's a thing.
- Yeah.
- Is that true, Joey?
- Yes.
(Garnt laughs)
Absolutely, I mean-
- Especially in other countries
with characters as well,
that's a big problem.
- Yeah, yeah 'cause when I was in school,
I took the Kanji proficiency test,
so obviously I was just
used to writing it all.
But once I got that degree,
I was like, "All right, cool,
I never have to write
this shit ever again."
And now when I look at it,
or now when someone's like,
"How do you write this?"
when someone's like,
I just kind of stop and I'm
like, "I should know this."
- Well you can read it, right?
So it doesn't matter.
- I can read it,
but I can't write it and there's
so many symbols like that.
- Yeah, you've done language
learning streams as well.
Japanese as well, isn't it?
How's that been going?
- I can't really do them as much anymore
because of certain permissions issues.
But I'm thinking of getting
back into it with just,
making a list of vocabulary beforehand,
and running through flashcards with chat.
Because I feel like
that can be entertaining
in its own way, I think.
Somehow it always becomes a fun time,
even ideas that I think are
going to be kind of boring,
it ends up being fun.
- You know what's amazed
me about streaming?
No matter what obscure thing I do,
just one God damn expert appears
out of nowhere in the chat.
(Joey laughs)
I'll be doing Sudoku and the
2017 world Sudoku champion
will come on my chat and be like,
"Hey, what are you doing?
This technique's cringe."
(Joey laughs)
You know what I mean?
No matter what I do, somehow,
an expert comes out of nowhere.
- What is this, fucking Reddit?
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
- It's insane, I'd be doing
a water grading stream,
and the guy who designed
water will appear in my chat.
(Garnt chuckles)
- "Hi, I discovered water."
- [Garnt] "I discovered water."
(Garnt laughs)
- It's insane, I don't
know how this happens,
no matter what I do.
- Connor, when he sees a Badei stream.
(Mori and Garnt laughs)
- A Toto CEO comes into my
chat, you're using it wrong.
- Kind of in the same vein,
sometimes there'll be a movie or a song
that I know for a fact only
10,000 people have heard
or listened to and someone
in chat knows about it.
Oh, I remember that.
Wait, do you?
And they do.
- Yeah, I'm the producer.
(everyone laughs)
- I made that.
- Of course.
- Or like that very
obscure childhood memory
that you have of a game or a
show and then you describe it,
and then chat is like, oh
yeah, I know what that is,
of course, I know what that is.
(Joey snickering)
I'm like, what?
- [Mori] Wild.
- How do you know that?
- Always be wild to me.
- What's wrong with you guys?
- They just know it, man.
- Chat is a curse,
but also like an almighty being
that just knows everything.
It's pretty impressive.
- It is.
- Or it's like a conglomerate, right?
It's weird, seeing people refer to chat,
it's like, yes, it's, I don't know,
such a weird concept to me.
'Cause everyone in chat
is a individual person,
but then chat just melds
into this one entity.
- An entity, yeah.
- One all-knowing entity
that is a equally-
- All single brain cell
that's joined together.
(Mori and Garnt laughs)
- Omnipotent, omnipresent being.
- [Mori] To make one brain.
- You get a 300 IQ.
Oh my God.
- [Mori] Yeah, that's right,
that's true.
- It's like being part of hololive,
of course you stream on YouTube,
but what do you think about
the whole Twitch streaming as well?
Have you ever been interested
in streaming on Twitch,
and what kind of differences
do you think that would make
if you ever did?
- It's pretty unexplored
territory to be honest,
so I haven't really
thought too much about it.
I feel like,
I have watched a couple
streamers on Twitch,
but for whatever reason,
I just feel like I gravitate
more towards YouTube.
I know that they both have
their pros and cons, for sure.
I've gotten so comfortable on YouTube.
And one thing that I really love about it,
on YouTube especially, is that archives
are kept forever.
So my streams become videos
that people can just watch
whenever they want and
check out the whole backlog.
I really love that,
but I do think that, for example,
Twitch's sub feature is superior.
That is for certain.
But I think they both
have their pros and cons,
I just feel at this point
it's like a comfort thing.
I'm just so used to YouTube
now and the way that people,
interact with each other in chat there.
There's so many layers to it
that I just kind of prefer.
- Yeah, I find it really
curious or really weird
to see both these platforms,
just having different
cultures around them.
And it's almost like
a different etiquette.
Like, when you're on a Twitch stream,
it feels completely different
to watching a YouTube stream.
And I'm not sure if
it's just the community
or if it's just emotes or what it is.
But yeah, both platforms
to me feel oddly different
whenever I'm watching a
different, greater stream
on that platform.
- There's a culture to it,
for sure, I have noticed
'cause I watched streamers
who stream on both,
and it is quite different, I got to say.
(Mori chuckles)
(Garnt laughs)
That's not me being, I'm not
throwing any shade at Twitch,
I'm just saying that-
- Throw shade at them.
(Garnt laughs)
Do it.
- [Mori] I mean, it's not for me.
- They're not paying you.
- [Mori] It's not for me,
but I mean, at the same time,
it's just what you prefer.
At the end of the day,
everyone's got their preference,
and just choose what you
like and that's how it goes.
- Like yeah, I don't think I'd have
a difficult time streaming on YouTube now
that I'm just so used to it.
- You're used to it, yeah.
You get used to it.
- Yeah and vice versa.
- The vibes different as well, I think.
- [Mori] Yeah, exactly.
- The vibe definitely
is totally different.
People are way more
joking on Twitch, I think.
People are used to-
- People are monkeys on Twitch.
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
- [Joey] Yeah, they are.
- We got a couple monkeys
on YouTube as well though.
- Oh that's true.
- But it is a, kind of
different feeling for sure.
At the end of the day though,
I will go to where the creator I like is,
that is the truth for me personally,
but that's not always
the case for everyone
everyone's kind of different.
- Some people are lazy to open
another tab, I don't get it.
- I get it, I mean-
(Chad, Mori, Joey and Connor laughs)
- Garnt is that guy.
- Clicking a link to go on
another platform, get outta here.
(Mori and Joey laughs)
No, I mean-
- Too much time.
- My poor fingy, can't handle it.
- No because, I mean,
there's just so many platforms nowadays,
and so many different apps and stuff
that sometimes you just-
- sounds like my mum.
"There's too many apps these days."
- I can't handle all the tabs.
- Sometimes you just build up
a, is schedule the right word?
No, it's a pattern, you build up a pattern
about what time you
spend on each app, right.
So I've been watching a lot
of YouTube shorts nowadays,
even though I could go,
and even though they're just
recycled TikToks, right.
But it's just because I'm, as a YouTuber,
I'm just on YouTube more.
That is just more convenient for me.
And so I don't like, if you
watch a lot of Twitch streamers,
then sure, it's easy to
watch more Twitch streamers.
But if you're not like
integrated into that kind
of ecosystem, it's weird.
'Cause it feels like you're going more out
of your way just to view
this one creator as opposed
to just being on the platform naturally.
So I do think it is a factor that matters,
which is why you see a lot
of people who are just famous
on one platform nowadays.
You can have people who
are famous on YouTube
and just not have a
presence anywhere else.
- Right.
- You know and I feel like
the super, super
successful content creators
are people who can break out of that,
just one platform and be
able to have a presence
on multiple platforms.
- I mean, I am a person who kind of feels
like consistencies is a big key,
but some people are so big
that it doesn't matter.
it doesn't matter where you go,
people will follow kind of thing.
But I do kind of see the
merit in having all your stuff
in one place.
It's also just personally what I prefer
because of how my brain works.
I like to have everything in one place,
'cause I'm already a
really big scatterbrain
in the first place.
If I had stuff all over the
place, I'd lose my mind.
So I kind of have to-
- You're juggling enough
things as it is, honestly.
(Garnt chuckles)
- Yeah, there's a lot going on, so.
- I'm just scared to have
everything on one platform.
I'm that mentality of,
don't put all your eggs in
one basket, kind of thing.
- [Mori] Oh I see.
- Yeah, I do think that,
however music is the one thing
that is easily able to hold its own.
I mean, that's why every
YouTuber on earth tries
to become a popstar or rapper.
- To varying levels of success.
- 'Cause that's where, money is good,
longevity is good, you can
have time to work on it.
Music is definitely-
- Also, it doesn't matter
how old you get, right.
You can still keep making music.
- Yeah, as long as it sounds good.
(Garnt laughs)
On YouTube, you turn 30, bye-bye.
Sorry Garnt, you're out.
(all laughing)
God, why was his reaction so.
See, I mean 30 years old,
man, it's what happens.
- I'm having trouble hearing already, man.
(Connor and Garnt laughs)
- It's me, really just
trying to age gate Garnt.
(Connor and Joey laughs)
- [Mori] You should become a VTuber.
- Go to, where do old people stream Garnt?
(Connor and Joey chuckles)
- I tried to say a platform, I was like,
I probably shouldn't.
- Justin.tv, that's where
I did my first stream.
- I'm sorry, we are
joking, we are friends,
we're allowed to make
these jokes, all right.
(Garnt laughs)
- It's like, you have to clarify
that you're bantering these days.
- [Connor] Yeah, I know, right?
- Let's calm down a little bit, you know.
- Oh God.
- Is it the same on a
hololive with the friends?
Do those people get upset
when you mock each other?
- I will say we like
to banter quite a bit,
but we got to remind y'all again
and we really don't have to,
but I'm going to anyway, we
are all really good friends.
- Yeah, exactly, yeah.
- And so at the same time,
a lot of us have kind of, I
mean, I know I certainly came up
in friend groups where we would,
throw shit at each other
and it was all in good fun.
We never really kind
of step over the line,
it's all stuff that
we're comfortable with.
And it's just good fun.
No one hates anyone.
Just, sometimes you gotta calm down,
take a step back.
We know each other pretty well,
and it's just like that,
sometimes, we're having fun.
- There's really just some people though
that just don't get
that whole bantering or,
when is it over the line?
There are people who are
overanalyze conversations on streams,
and YouTube videos where
it's like, this is the frame,
this is the very frame where
their friendship started to crumble.
Have you seen them streaming since then?
(Mori laughs)
- So dramatic.
- Don't think so,
not friends anymore.
It's like, no, dude, it's fine.
- Yeah, I feel even more so
with the VTubing community.
Do you ever feel like a lot of people
really, really analyze
what your behaviors are?
- Yeah.
- And maybe a bit too much sometimes?
- Yeah I'd say so, I've
seen several paragraphs
analyzing my personality.
From my deepest insecurities to things
that everyone already knows, etcetera.
I've seen plenty of things like that.
And it's gonna happen, it's gonna happen.
When so much of yourself is put out there,
that's just how it's gonna be.
But I will say it is the
truth, we really do only give
a percentage of ourselves when we stream,
even though it may be
so many hours in a day,
there's still a whole side
where we go off and live lives.
I'm still, occasionally reaping
the occasional soul, don't
tell Death Sensei about that.
But I'm doing other stuff as well.
And it's important to remember that,
it's important to take a deep breath
and realize that we've all got lives.
- So where does music
fit into your career?
How do you find time for that?
Where do you find time for that?
- I think that the only
only thing I can say is,
it's the one thing that I
love doing so completely
and utterly, that time,
just isn't a factor to me,
energy isn't a factor to me.
All of that just disappears in me wanting
to create music and I don't
compromise anything for it.
- I believe that's called a passion.
(Joey snickers)
(Garnt laughs)
- That sounds like a passion to me.
- Yeah, I think that is the word.
- Yeah, sounds like passion to me.
- So no matter what, I will
find a way to fit it in.
Even if other things have to
kind of, take a back seat.
Even things like streaming, etcetera,
which will not make everyone happy
but you get over it, you get over it.
At the end of the day it's what I love.
- Yeah prioritise what
you want to do, right?
- Exactly.
- [Joey] Yeah, exactly.
- Why else am I here, you know?
- Just to suffer.
- [Mori] Just to suffer.
- I wanted to say it.
- [Mori] There's no other reason.
- That's what I thought of.
- We all thought it, we all thought it.
- You can't not say that line
and not make me think that.
- Exactly, I mean, if that
was the case, then I'd quit.
And I mean, if you want me to stay here,
I'm going to do what I want
to do, that's all I can say.
(scene swooshes)
- This episode is sponsored by Zenmarket.
- Gentlemen, you know what sometimes
can be a little bit tricky?
- What?
- Buying items in Japan.
Well, the sponsor of today's episode,
Zenmarket makes being an
anime fan so much easier.
Want to get your hands on some
of that exclusive anime merchandise
only available in Japan?
- I do kinda, in fact, I recently bought
a JoJo stone mask that you
see in the part one anime.
I bought it exclusively
at the JoJo exhibit
that is only held here in Japan.
- And look at this Rui mousepad.
- Did you bring that here?
- I did.
I have the Hina one at home,
which is the better one,
so if you want to get the Hina mousepad,
then you can buy that from Zenmarket too.
- [Joey] For a flat fee
of only 300 yen per item,
Zenmarket gives you access to
all the items we mentioned,
and so much more.
- Even though we live
in Japan, even for us,
the language barrier can
make things difficult.
Joey, shut the fuck up.
Well, fret no more because Zenmarket's
impeccable customer support team
provides native customer
support in over 14 languages.
- [Joey] Shee.
- [Garnt] And on top of that,
they offer a wide range
of payment options,
including PayPal and even cryptocurrency.
- We live in a society.
So no more waiting around for the day
you'll finally be able to visit Japan,
go over to our very own
Trash Taste landing page,
link in the description below,
and check out some of the
amazing Japanese exclusive merch
Zenmarket ships directly to your doorstep.
Back to the episode.
(scene swooshes)
- Do you find it hard to bring
that energy to your stream?
Even though your schedule
is obviously so busy.
There must be some
streams where you're like,
guys today, I'm just done,
honestly, I can't do it today.
- Oh, that's another thing that I,
kind of had to start learning,
is management of energy.
Because even if you want to
stream all the time, every day,
to see chat, to make them happy, etcetera.
At the end at the end of the day,
I only have so much energy and
chat's not going to have fun,
'cause they can tell when I'm low energy.
Like I said, I've seen
paragraphs analyzing
every single facet of my personality.
They can tell when you're
low energy, that's the truth.
So sometimes it's worth
it to give yourself
a little more breathing room.
Occasionally though, I get
a little ahead of myself,
schedule too many
streams, it be like that.
And it's taking quite a toll on my energy,
and after I'm done streaming,
I just go lay down.
And that's the only thing
I do besides streaming
and making music, is sleeping.
So it's something that I-
- How much sleep do you get per day?
- Six hours a night,
which is not terrible,
but it's not perfect.
- I think you need a
little bit more than that.
- Yeah, so I'm trying to
work on that a little bit,
but there's just a lot to do.
And there's a lot that you
have to put your energy into.
And when it comes to music,
one thing that I've noticed
is that it takes a little less energy
for me simply because there's no pressure
about making mistakes on stream.
In your work process,
nobody really sees all the awful mistakes
that you make when you're
recording a hundred takes
over and over again.
You put it together and
the song that you've made
is hopefully, if you've done it right,
the best possible thing
that you could have made it be, right.
With streaming, it's just
go, be good at improv,
be good at games, be good
at something and just pray.
- Be perfect for the next two hours.
- Yeah, exactly and just pray.
And that takes a lot of energy out of you.
there's a lot of stress
that comes with that.
That maybe you can be
really good at hiding,
maybe you're not so good at hiding it.
It just depends, man and it's rough.
It's-
- I feel like you've got to learn it along
the way as well because no
one's ever prepared to be like,
"Okay, I'm going to stream
even though I'm low energy."
And sometimes you have to
just force it out of you,
and it's so difficult
'cause that's why I don't
stream so often as well,
because I also have a
certain amount of energy,
and if it's below that,
then it's just not going
to be a good stream.
- I think that a lot of the times though,
when you feel rough or you
don't feel like you've got
the energy for a stream,
often, that when you actually
start and get into it,
you kind of get into the rhythm of it,
and you kind of get a lot
more energy as you go.
- It also depends on what you're doing.
There are some streams
where you're just like,
"I'm having a good time playing this",
or "I'm having a good
time doing this activity."
And there some streams
where you're just like,
"This isn't an okay time and I'll have
to make it seem like it's a lot more fun
than just an okay time."
- I mean, I do got to admit,
I think I barely scraped by
in terms of the personality
you need to stream because
not everyone can stream.
You have to have a certain
kind of personality.
I don't know if you guys know this,
but I've seen it a couple
quote, unquote, reliable,
scientific research papers or whatever.
Somebody said something on the internet,
and I took it as fact.
But I believe it.
I can only-
(Garnt laughs)
- There's some big air quotations on that.
- I can understand this being true,
so I'm not saying this is a fact,
but I don't think the
human brain was meant
to deal with 10,000 or so
people watching you all
at one time and what you're doing.
- 100%.
- 100%..
- Humans weren't built to do that.
- 100%.
- We weren't built for it.
Now, technically I'm
not a human but listen.
(Garnt and Connor laughs)
I have a human body, so we're going-
- Throw out the research paper.
(Connor chuckles)
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
- Exactly.
But we really aren't meant to,
so you have to have a
certain kind of personality
to not mentally collapse.
- What is that personality?
- You have to have a little bit of an ego.
You have to have just a smidge.
It just needs to be a little
bit, it needs to be enough.
Because not everyone can do
it, that's just the truth.
You have to have a certain
kind of personality,
you can't brute force it and that's fine.
That is absolutely okay but
it's just kind of how it is.
You can build it up yourself
but it is a prerequisite.
- Do you see yourself doing streaming
for a much longer time?
Or do you think there's like
a certain amount of time?
Where you're just like,
"Yeah, I'm probably going
to try something different
after a certain amount of time."
- Right, like a time limit on this?
It does take more energy for me
than some other folks, I think.
And with that being said,
I think that I'd like to try it out,
and continue on for a longer time.
However, the frequency with
which I do it may change
at some point because-
- Yeah I mean-
- Yeah, I'll be thoroughly impressed
if you can keep this for the next year.
- Have you heard about this
thing, it's called weekends.
It's where most people-
- A holiday.
- Holidays as well.
(Garnt laughs)
- The fabled holiday,
I've heard of that before.
Yeah, but in a sense, these days,
I kind of find myself sitting down
after a stream being like,
"All right, break time,
watch something on Netflix."
And I think to myself,
"I want to do something work-related."
And that's when you've become a workaholic
and you need to fix that.
- You've got the illness.
- So it's good but I
often found the struggle
where I would sometimes
invest too heavily in work.
And then I would think,
"Oh, I just haven't hung out
with anyone in a long time."
(Joey chuckles)
And I feel kind of lonely.
But then I've spent too much time working
and I can't hang out with people
because they're hanging out with people
who are more consistent
(laughing) hanging out,
which is totally fair, right.
- What do you mean?
Well, because if you're
often not available,
people don't invite you to things, right?
So if everyone knows that
you're not going to turn up
to stuff most of the time,
people stop inviting you.
- They give up.
- So you kind of have to
balance very carefully
and like, going to stuff,
but also wanting to be there for work.
Because I also feel the
same way with streaming
where I'm like, "Oh, I'm not there enough.
I'm not participating in
the ecosystem enough."
So it's a struggle.
Do you ever have that problem?
- All the time.
(Connor chuckles)
But I mean, recently I've
been trying to fix that
by instead reaching out to
people that I haven't talked to,
and be like, hey I'm here.
- That's yeah, that's my work around.
It's because people, if I get to the point
where people stop inviting
me because I get too busy,
get your brain.
I stopped.
- No, no, I do,
I have to have a schedule.
- I'm gonna take a step.
- I'll make my own events.
- I'll be like, now, all
I want to do is work,
but I'll schedule something
in like two weeks.
'Cause it's not right
now, it's not right now,
it's not work right now.
Then it comes around and I'm
like, "Fuck I want to work."
But I'm glad I scheduled
that because now can actually
force myself to go and have a good time,
and not think about doing work.
- I feel like moving
has helped you as well
'cause I remember before,
you never invite people
to your place at all because-
- It was a mess.
- Well, Pewdiepie roasted me.
(Mori and Garnt laughs)
- It was terrible and it was also too far.
- But now you're in a more central place,
so it's easier to just invite people,
and sort out your own place.
- Because when I lived an hour away,
like a minimum of an hour journey.
An hour is a long time to lose in a day
when I try and make every
God damn hour count.
So when two hours, 'cause
there and back, right?
now it's a lot quicker for me,
which is great for most places.
But yeah, I would spend
so much time traveling,
and I'm not the kind of person
who can work on a train.
I don't know about you.
- Yeah, definitely not Tokyo trains.
Yeah, If I'm standing,
there's absolutely no
way I can do any work.
And then sometimes-
- I can, I figured out a way.
Do you get this thing though, sometimes?
- How, how?
What work do you do on a train?
(Mori chuckles)
- Well, I can answer emails,
I can work on scripts
'cause you can do it all on the phone.
- Fuck off, can you work on
scripts on the train, Joey.
(Mori and Garnt laughs)
- Do you ever have, I don't know if this
is another thing or this
is just a me thing, right?
I have these things, right, it's an email,
but it's an email that I
need to sit down and look at.
It's a focus email, I can't
do it when I'm standing.
I got to sit down and
be like, "Okay, okay."
- [Mori] 100%.
- Yeah, I don't have that (chuckles).
- You don't?
I'm envious of you.
- I have that.
I can't answer important
emails on my phone,
I need to sit down on
a laptop or a computer
or something.
- It feels so much nicer.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- A computer, have the big screen,
so I can think about my
words on a bigger resolution.
I don't know why that matters.
- Do you activate different
neurons when you sit down?
- Calli back me up here.
Do you do this?
- I mean, I agree, actually, entirely,
especially when it comes to music.
Though, sometimes I'll be
on a plane, on a train,
I get my phone out, I'm
like, "I'm ready to work."
And I'm like, "Nope, time for a nap."
And I just put my phone away-
- People who work on planes are like,
just what happened in their childhood?
(Mori laughs)
- Oh no, I can work on planes.
- What happened in your childhood?
- I can work on planes.
- That's fucked up.
- Oh my God, how?
- Working on a plane is different
than working on a train, okay.
- No, man.
You work on a plane?
- With a train-
- Yeah.
(Garnt laughs)
- Oh my God.
- [Mori] Oh my God.
- You're like this in the fucking cabin,
there's people next to you,
they bring the food over,
you're like, "Oh shit,
the fucking laptop."
'Cause on a plane, you are-
- I do it on my phone.
- No.
- No, no, you don't work
on your phone, Joey.
(Mori and Chad laughs)
You need a fucking laptop
or at least a tablet, a phone?
- That's pretty rough.
- You can't work on a plane right?
- No, I mean, what happens
is, I think I'm going to,
so I bring my laptop.
- The three levels of psychopaths.
- I bring it in the carry on
and I put it on the table,
and I'm ready to work.
And then suddenly someone
comes with a glass
of Chardonnay and they're
like, "Here you go."
I'm like, "All right, well,
I've got to find a
freaking place for this."
Then turn on the thing and
I'm looking at the map,
and I'm like, "I wonder
what movies they have?"
And suddenly I'm looking at the movies.
"Holy shit they have this
one I wanted to watch."
- See, if I was in like
first class or business,
had the whole fucking thing
set up yet, yeah, okay,
maybe we can talk about working.
When I'm in economy, I'm just depressed.
I don't want to think about work,
I want to watch whatever
Jason Statham movie
is on this plane.
- No, I'm depressed because
there's no good movies on.
It's always shit movies, which I hate.
It's plane movies, so if I'm
going to be in a bad mood,
I might as well be in a
bad mood and do some work.
That's my-
- That's exactly why I hate
watching movies on a plane,
because for one they're all
movie I don't want to watch.
So I'm like, "Well, what is there to do?"
I'm not just going to
blankly stare out the window.
- I just sleep.
- [Mori] Take a nap.
- I don't know, yeah, I just sleep.
- Okay when I say-
- [Garnt] When I can
sleep, when I can sleep.
- When I say work on a plane,
I'm not working the whole fucking trip.
- Yeah, Joey's making calls,
sell my stock God damn it.
- I haven't seen my kids in three days.
(Joey, Connor and Garnt laughs)
Okay, if I'm flying from
Tokyo to LA, it's like what?
10, 11 hour flight.
- I'm probably working, max,
like three or four hours.
- [Garnt] Yeah, same here.
- How the fuck?
- The rest of the time I'm reading a book,
or taking a nap or watching
a movie, God forbid.
Doing something else, basically.
I'm not that much of a fucking machine
where I'm like, "11 hours
on this flight, all right.
11 full hours of work."
- Mudan is the only guy.
- Yeah, Mudan is the only one.
- The final stage.
- Puts his desktop on the plane.
(Garnt laughs)
- No, Mudan's the type of guy who's like,
"Oh, you need to video edit it,
let me whip out my phone real quick."
(Joey laughs)
- Oh my God, he's done that.
- Yeah, right.
- He's done that before.
- Has he actually?
- He's used the remote
control on his phone
to edit on his PC.
- [Chad] Yeah, it's just like a virtual-
- That's what I'm saying,
this guy's plugged
into the matrix.
This is it, this is when
you reach your final form.
This is the final evolution of humans.
(Mori and Garnt laughs)
How'd you script on your phone?
Especially if you're standing up
in a crowded train, it's impossible
for me to get the right mindset.
I can't get a single thought together.
- So if I'm in a crowded
train, I'm not writing script.
I'm doing the research for the script.
'Cause it's easy enough to just,
'cause you already own your
phone on a crowded train,
looking at Twitter or whatever.
So what's the difference between looking
at Twitter and looking at a web page,
or an anime news site or something.
- I'd just watch Philip de Franco.
- Yeah, or a YouTube video, right?
It's the same motion but I'm not there
fucking typing it out on a
crowded train, obviously not.
If I'm sitting down on a train,
sure I can whip it out and
start typing some shit in,
but I don't know.
- I wish I had that power, man.
(Garnt laughs)
- I mean if you did that,
you'd probably be able
to upload every week.
(Joey, Mori and Garnt laughs)
- Maybe that's what's missing.
- He got fired.
- [Connor] I don't think
it's that, as much he wishes.
- Pa, pa, pa, poh, shots fired.
- I mean, do you find you have
to be in a certain environment
when you write your music?
Or is it just whenever inspiration hits?
- That's a good question.
To be completely honest, I
can't force it, I just can't.
Sometimes I'm in the
mood to write this song,
sometimes I'm not.
And if I force it,
then the lyrics are
gonna turn out real bad.
So I just have to be really
mindful of when I'm feeling
that inspiration though.
It does get a bit stronger
as the deadline creeps up.
It's not procrastination,
I promise, it's just-
- That's what they all say.
(Garnt laughs)
- I feel that making music is
a completely different part
of your brain that doesn't overlap
with any other type of activity.
- [Mori] Definitely.
- Yeah, I couldn't write music on a plane
or anywhere that's not my room.
And even when I'm in
my room, I need to be,
as Calli said, I need to
be in a specific mood.
- That's me and scripting.
I need to be in a specific mood.
I can do admin stuff on my
phone and shit like that,
but scripting's sacred.
- That's probably why your scripting
is way better than mine.
- It sounds like you have that
with everything though, Garnt.
Sounds like you have to be
in the mood to shit as well.
(Mori and Chad laughs)
- I mean, there's nothing wrong
with being in the mood to shit.
(Connor laughs)
- This man, everything needs to be in
the monk-like zen mode
to get anything done.
"Garnt can you order some food now?"
- "I need to be in the right
mindset to open up Uber eats."
- I just get distracted too easily.
- You do, you do.
Genius take a takes a while.
(Garnt laughs)
Yeah, if you stopped, like
if you actually opened
the fucking app.
(Joey and Garnt laughs)
- That's why I need the certain apps
that I'm comfortable with.
I want to stay on those apps.
Don't give me anything new,
TikTok scares me, okay.
Yes, I'm a boomer, okay.
Say it, say it!
(Mori and Joey laughs)
- No, no, it's okay Garnt,
you're going to age way better than me.
It's fine, I'm just jealous.
- He has the upper hand now.
- How does it feel looking
at Chris and being like,
"I'm going to be that in five years?"
(Mori and Garnt laughs)
- [Mori] They don't
stop and they don't stop
and they don't stop.
- We all know it's true though,
come on we all know it's true.
- Chris looks good, Chris
looks good, Chris is great.
Yeah, I'll be bald at Chris's age.
(Connor and Mori laughs)
Oh my God.
Sad but true, sad but true,
pray for me, oh my God.
What's your favorite live streaming meme?
Or words that they use 'cause
live stream has its own lingo.
- That's right, let me
think, let me think.
- I don't think I've ever
seen Calli throw out the KEKW.
- [Mori] I can't.
- Or the Pog or anything like that.
- [Mori] I just can't.
- You know KEKW, you know Sangh?
- That's because she's not on Twitch.
- I can't do it, I wish I had it in me.
- Are you able to say the
word Pog or KEKW without-
- No, I can't.
(Garnt laughs)
It's too much for me.
- You can't give out a
MonkaS, every now and then?
(Joey and Garnt laughs)
- I know I'm pretty cringe here and there,
but that's just a little,
it's a little too much.
I think I might collapse into
myself like a black hole.
(Garnt, Joey and Chad laughs)
I can't do it, man.
- What's your go-to?
- Pepehands.
- Oh, Pepehands.
- [Garnt] Oh.
- That's all you're going to get from me
because somebody's been sending me
Pepehands Supers, recently
and yeah, it stays in my mind.
- Is there a meme you'd
like to see pop up?
- Ah, let's see.
Let me think, let me think.
I have to think really carefully about how
I answer this one 'cause
there's a hot debate.
- Every conversation
or question you ask is meme related.
- [Mori] In my chat right now.
- I do want to know what
people's tastes in memes are,
so I can kind of gauge their
level of internet prowess.
- We don't do a lot of memes in my chat.
I feel like, there's not-
- YouTubers vs Twitch streamers, right?
(Garnt chuckles)
- Yeah, it's hard because
I feel like it depends
on the chat, right?
I'm certainly not, for example,
it's not that everyone in holo EN's chats
are averse to memes, no, no
it's just the crowd that I've attracted,
I think isn't super hardcore
and we still have a few.
- Yeah, sometimes I'll
go to a VTuber's stream
and I'll watch it and I'll
just not understand it.
And they'll be like, oh
my God, they said banana,
it's the thing, it's the
thing, it's the in-joke.
And I'm like, "What's going on?"
- [Mori] There are a lot of those.
- I feel like that applies
for every YouTuber.
- No, no it doesn't.
I know with Twitch, at least, I think,
I feel like I haven't seen that much.
- I feel like that applies
to me and Twitch, honestly.
- [Connor] Oh, what?
- The in-jokes?
- Yeah, the in-jokes on Twitch.
Just 'cause I don't spend enough time
watching Twitch streams.
- I don't know, maybe I'm
just talking out my ass.
- I feel that on Twitch it's-
- I'm talking out my ass for real.
- I feel that with Twitch,
it's multiple layers.
It's like, it starts off
with a Twitch reference,
that is specific to Twitch
and then that evolves
into an in-joke.
So it's like multiple layers
that you have to understand.
Whereas on YouTube there
isn't really specific lingo,
I guess, I don't know.
- Oh, no, with hololive it's, I think,
all the memes that come from
the subreddit, I assume, right?
- Oh, that's right,
there are a lot of things
popping off there, I think for sure but-
- I mean, it's the same
with Trash Taste, right?
A lot of the memes come
from the subreddit.
(Garnt laughs)
- [Garnt] That's true, that is true.
- They come from
somewhere that's for sure.
But I mean-
- That's what we need
Reddit for, just the memes.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, keep up to date.
- Yeah, just keep up to date
with all the memes, right?
- I mean, I guess, occasionally,
it's just little things,
it's not necessarily just
words being spammed in chat,
but rather things that
I do or make a habit of.
For example, my intro and outro,
a lot of times when I started the stream,
I'll turn up the reverb and
echo and I'll just say, "Gah."
And then everyone in
the chat just says guh.
Or they use the guh
emote, that's about it.
"Hi, Calli, how are you?"
Hey, that's it, that's about it.
And then at the end,
everyone says, "Peace."
Turn up the reverb, turn
up the echo, "Peace."
And everyone spams peace in the chat,
but it's not just like word after word,
that's the same kind of thing.
Not a lot of, emotes.
Of course, you pull out the glow sticks
and the music emote for the live shows.
But that's about the extent
of where it goes to, I think.
Now for others in EN, I can
see it being kind of different.
They've all got their own personal,
inside jokes and words
people like to say in chat
but people get frustrated
about that sometimes,
'cause not everybody's a big fan
of the same memes being used
over again and over again,
it's chat, there's a lot of fighting.
- Yeah, it also makes
it difficult sometimes
for new people to come in.
If it's just all in-jokes, right.
It's important to maintain the balance of,
"Hey chat, shut the fuck up."
- 'Cause you also don't want
to be that guy that's like,
"What does this mean chat?"
There's that pressure as well.
- Yeah, exactly.
I guess the closest thing we ever got was,
you guys know Adam Sandler?
- Yeah, of course.
(Joey and Garnt laughs)
- Anyway.
- Just the way you said that.
- Is that like a underground acter?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This underground new YouTuber-
- You said it like it was an
avant garde musical artist
that we'd never heard of.
- It's like me going,
"Do you guys this guy
called Nicholas Cage?"
(Mori laughs)
- "Do you know Barack Obama?"
(Joey laughs)
- [Mori] Yeah, I dunno how
relevant Ol' Adam is these days.
- So where is this
going with Adam Sandler?
- I mean, he just has become
like a prominent figure
in the lore.
Same with Shrek.
- [Connor] What?
- It's just it's stuff like that-
- When isn't Adam Sandler?
- And here's where new people
getting into the stream
would maybe get confused.
- So how is Adam Sandler playing the part?
- He's just always kind of
been there, like his spirit.
(Connor laughs)
- What?
- [Mori] It's hard to explain.
- He's still alive, right?
- A long time ago there was an event-
(Mori laughs)
- He's still doing well.
- A long time ago, there was an event
where we all canonically we
erased it from our brains.
And I've been having
trouble remembering it.
- [Connor] Like "Click."
- And there was the existence of an emote,
I believe, I can't remember
what it looks like.
And I don't remember what we called it,
but I know Ol' Adam was involved,
and we banished it from the chat.
We had like a burning
ceremony and everything.
After watching Adam's
movies, I can't remember it.
- Is this like your
Mandela effect in motion
or something like that?
- We get a little crazy sometimes.
- I'm missing so many parts
of the context of this story.
- We've jumped right to
the exile of Adam Sandler.
(Mori laughs)
How do we get to the exile?
How did it even begin?
- I mean, I was just kind of like,
listen, when I was a young baby Reaper,
mama Mori often put Ol' Adam on the screen
when she went off to work
and I'd watch Ol' Adam back then,
just me and my Adam Sandler movies.
- Just me and Adam.
- And of course it came up again in chat
and people were like, "Oh,
what movies do you like?"
And I was like, "Have you
guys seen, 'Happy Gilmore?"
And they're like, "Heh, Adam Sandler."
- I love Happy Gilmore, it's great.
- Happy Gilmore's great, yeah.
- I actually do think that's a good movie.
- What are your favorite
Adam Sandler movies?
- "Mr. Deeds."
- [Connor] I love "Mr. Deeds."
- I've not seen that one.
- It's such a good one,
it's why I recommend it.
- My favorite scene is
when he's hitting his foot.
- Yeah and his foot's
black from the frostbite,
yeah, that's right.
I remember my first curse
words from that movie.
- I don't remember that scene,
I've seen the movie, I
don't remember the scene.
- I've seen, I think, "50 First Dates."
- Oh yeah, that one's not bad.
- That's actually a good one.
- Yeah, I think that's a good one and-
- [Joey] I think, "Click's" my favorite.
- "Click's" a pretty good one too.
- [Connor] "Click's" good.
- Anger management.
Oh, Sydney showed me "Wedding
Singer," the other day,
'cause I was talking about Adam Sandler.
- Why were you talking about Adam Sandler?
- I can't remember.
- [Joey] Why does Adam
just creep into everyone's-
- Shit, why was I talking
about Adam Sandler?
- Adam just creeps into
everyone's subconcious.
- Sydney, why was I talking
about Adam Sandler again?
- [Sydney] What?
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
- Oh, she's in the other room right now.
- What was I going to say?
Good Ol' Adam, he's
become like a presence,
and it's hard to explain why,
but he just creeped in.
Have you guys seen "Uncut Gems"?
- It's amazing.
- I've been trying to get
these guys to watch it,
it's such a good movie.
- I remember you talking about it, yeah.
He's so good, it's like he's
actually acting for once.
(Joey laughs)
Like he's actually trying.
- Exactly.
- My movie list is like
my anime to watch list,
which is like, yeah, I'll
watch it someday and then-
- They're all movies I've
heard of, but I'm just like,
"Yeah, I'll get to it, eventually."
- If I watch it, it's good.
- What will get me now is,
sometimes memes just get me the urge
to watch certain movies now.
"Megamind" memes have been
coming up more recently.
I'm just like, "I should watch-
- Have you watched the movie?
It's really good.
- [Garnt] I have not watched "Megamind."
I've heard it's really good,
I've heard it's really ahead of it's time.
Yeah and just seeing the memes,
I saw the memes and I'm just like,
"Let me watch a few clips."
And then I'm like,
"Oh, maybe I should sit
down and watch this."
Maybe I'll do that tonight, actually.
Now, I'm thinking about it.
(Joey and Mori laughs)
I'll watch "Megamind" tonight.
- Or do you also have to
be in the right mindset
to watch that?
(Joey, Mori and Garnt laughs)
- It's literally "Megamind," Garnt.
It's a kid's movie, you don't
have to be in a mindset.
- Is that Pixar?
It's not Pixar, it's Dreamworks right?
- [Connor] No, no, it's Dreamworks.
- I have to be in certain moods
to watch entertainment, okay.
- I can understand that too.
- I'm a very picky person.
- But Adam Sandler, Dreamworks,
and that kind of stuff,
that's supposed to be the type
of genre that does so well,
because you can watch it, anytime.
- That's right.
- Oh, but sometimes,
when you watch a show,
or something that people
have been talking about,
and you just watch it just to keep up.
- "Megamind" is not a clay masterpiece,
you don't need to pay attention,
you just watch it all right.
- I want to pay attention
to the shit I watch Connor.
I want to pay attention to it.
- If there was a genre of
entertainment that does very well
because you don't need
to pay attention to it.
- It's the brain dead entertainment.
- [Mori] Turn off your brain.
- Yeah, brain dead.
- Even in the brain dead
stuff, I like to pay attention
just because-
- Even when you're making thumbnails.
- Yeah, exactly, stuff like that
Stuff that you can do other stuff-
- I thought that's what
YouTube videos were for.
I thought that was what
Trash Taste was for,
that's the brain dead content, right?
(Joey and Garnt laughs)
- Don't sell ourselves thin.
- Hard to do when you're
watching subs though.
If you've got subtitles though
it's kind of a little harder.
- The Trash Taste, YouTubes
most brain dead podcast.
- 'Cause sometimes you put
on a YouTube video, right,
sometimes you put it on the second monitor
and then it starts and you're like,
"Oh, oh, oh, this is some
main monitor shit, oh, okay."
- [Joey] When you switch it over.
- And then you have to swap
it over to the main monitor.
You're like, "Oh, okay."
That's how you know it's top tier content,
when it's not on your second monitor,
it's on your main monitor, man.
- I get that, I get that.
- And that, to me, it's just every movie,
I can't have a movie on
in the background, right.
- No, I can't do that either.
- I can do that.
- [Garnt] I know you can.
- Can you do that?
- It's tough these days
because I actually don't really
consume a lot of media, sadly enough.
- 'Cause you're streaming
nine hours a day, every day.
- I have an issue where if
I really get into a series,
I have to finish it in one go.
Recently I was reading a manga
that I got into the other night,
it's been out for a long time.
(Joey, Garnt and Connor laughs)
- I thought you said, Amung Us.
- No, not Amung Us, please, no Amung Us.
No, I can't, honestly
with the Amung Us, oh no.
- I'm glad I wasn't the only one.
I looked at Garnt and
we just made eye contact
and we were like, "Among Us?"
Among Us.
- That game just infiltrates
everyone's brains, I swear.
- I've never heard anyone proud
to pronounce it, Amung Us.
- Amung Us, did I really say it like that?
- You said it like that.
- Oh God, I can't believe it,
I'll never forgive myself.
- I just love how we all were,
all three of us just perked up
and just looked at each other.
It's like, "Amung Us."
Sorry, sorry, we completely-
- No, it's okay, it's actually kind of,
it's not a super new one,
it's called, what was it?
I believe in Japanese it's
called (speaking Japanese).
- Oh yeah, "Alice In Borderland."
- Oh the Netflix show.
- Yeah, yeah,
I read the whole manga.
Yeah I watched the Netflix show,
I watched all of it and I was
like, "This is pretty good."
And so I just had to figure
out what the ending was.
And so I read the whole
manga from start to finish
in one day and I was like,
"I could have done a lot of other stuff,
but I had to keep reading it."
- Was it worth it?
- Yeah, it was good, I liked it.
I thought the ending
was okay, it was fine.
But I thought the writing and
the emotional writing was,
it gets a little much,
sometimes like a little edgy,
but overall I thought
it was very well done,
so I recommended it.
- I think it's just like
most survival horror mangas.
It's just like a little touch of too edgy.
- By the way, this is not
because of "Squid Game"
that I've been getting into,
"Kaiji" and stuff like that,
I liked "Kaiji" and-
- You liked "Kaiji" before it was cool.
- No.
(Mori laughs)
But I've been into death game stuff,
before "Squid Game" popped up.
- Well, it's your job, right?
- Yeah.
- I have to do my research.
- It's a form of inspiration.
- Damn those things are good.
- Like, aw shit, why
didn't I think of that?
Fuck.
- I don't know, not "Squid Game,"
just death game manga
and anime are definitely
some of my guilty pleasures.
Because there are some,
I think in terms of the tier
of well-written death games,
I think "Squid Game's" on the side
of the better written ones,
even though it is a bit edgy sometimes.
But sometimes you just read
something like that is just
pure edge and for some reason, it's just,
I don't know, man, it's
like junk food for me.
- I can name about 10.
- Yeah.
- A lot of them do feel quite
samey after a while though.
- Yeah.
- "Cause you're just like, "Oh, okay."
- You start to be able to predict things
the way the games are gonna go.
- It's because they're all
influenced by each other.
So it's like, there's only so much
you can do until someone is like,
"No, no, let me try something else."
- Have you watched, "Squid Game" done yet?
- I have, I did, I watched
it again all in one night,
'cause I couldn't take a break.
- Me too.
- Yeah and I thought it was very good.
I thought it was a very solid
show and I liked it a lot.
Of course there are things
that I wasn't super into,
but overall I liked it.
- Yeah, it definitely
wasn't the perfect show,
but really good.
- Grim Reaper approves.
- What I find interesting
about the whole "Squid Game,"
like getting mainstream stuff
now is I've seen so many
debates about the subs versus
dub in the mainstream now.
And it's so surreal, right?
- I mean, some of the
dubbing in "Squid Game" was-
- I keep getting
recommending clips of some
of the dub clips of "Squid Game."
And I'm just like, "How are
people watching this right now?"
'Cause I think, I can't remember,
I think I saw it on Philip DeFranco where
there was a metric of how
many people watched it dubbed.
I think it was like 60 or like 69% people-
- More people watched it dubbed?
- 'Cause people on Netflix,
when you do it,
if you've got your
language set to English,
it just automatically linked.
So a lot of people don't
want to then flip to-
- I think it's, well for some
countries the original Korean,
voices just weren't available.
- What?
- 'Cause like I remember my sister
was telling me in Australia,
there was no option other
than the English dub.
Like you have to watch it in English dub.
And she's like, "What the fuck?"
I don't want to watch it in English dub.
But yeah.
So I think it also depends
on the country as well.
- It's interesting because I actually
I've watched Netflix shows with the dub
when they aren't originally, like,
when it's a different
language, other than English,
I've watched English dubs on Netflix
that I didn't think were terrible,
but that was something special, yeesh man.
(Garnt and Joey laughs)
- Half the actors are
speaking in a different
type of English.
I think half the voice
actors are Americans
and the other half are British.
- The old woman just doesn't
sound like an old woman.
You know that should be the first thing
that you try and do to at least give
a little bit of effort to
not sound like a 25 year old.
- Yeah, from the clips I've seen,
it definitely gives me the impression
that none of the dubbed voice actors
knew how big this was going to be.
- I don't think anyone involved.
- I don't think even Netflix knew
how big this was gonna be.
And you can definitely see it.
Yeah, because, yeah, I don't know.
Maybe it's just because
we're in the anime community,
but for me, especially when
it comes to live action,
I can't imagine watching
live action in anything
but the original language.
- It's so jarring.
- Although it is also a
guilty pleasure of mine.
Every now and then I watch
a live action Hollywood film
with the Japanese dub.
- Why, Joey, why?
- It's so funny.
- It is funny.
- And even when they get top voice actors
in the animesphere to voiceover Vin Diesel
in fucking "Fast and Furious,"
I'm just like, it's so weird.
It's so weird to hear a different voice
that's not Vin Diesel's come out
of Vin Diesel's mouth,
yeah, it's very funny.
- [Mori] You've peaked my curiousity.
- You should, it's really funny.
- And then luckily in Japan,
normally all the movies are
in subbed in the cinema,
which is thank you
because I can watch them.
- It's all the ones that make it to DVD,
that have an option.
- Yeah, DVD, they have a
option, thank God, thank God,
thank you, Japan.
I can actually enjoy going to the cinema.
- It is weird watching like Japanese dubs
of Western cartoons though, that is weird.
Like-
- Oh like "Simpsons?"
Yeah, Simpsons, like hearing
Japanese, Rick and Morty
as well was that was so surreal.
- Japanese Rick and Morty.
(Mori laughs)
- [Joey] So weird.
- That's when I can kind of get behind it
because it actually suits it
a lot in a lot of the scenes.
Like whoever voices Rick
fucking blew it out of the park.
- Did a great job.
- I wanna go listen to this now.
- It's not bad.
- Okay shit, okay, okay.
- This is the only, being
on the other side of things
where it's like, oh no,
not all dubs are bad.
Even if it's like, originally
in English for once.
- Trash Taste is better
in Russia, everyone knows.
- Yeah, Connor in Russian
Trash Tastes sounds like
he sounds like he wrestles
bears for a living.
- I really, really am envious of that man.
- So have you had like
time to watch anything else
in your schedule or is it just like-
- Just random stuff?
- Recently I've been,
I got really into like,
it's a super obscure like
Yakuza film series called,
I know what it's called in English,
Battles without honor or humanity.
I need to figure out what the name-
- That is the most Google
translated title I've ever heard.
- I need to find the name of it
and I wish I could look it up.
- So what's the plot of this?
- Its a really long plot.
It's just about this one guy
and his entire experience
from start to finish
entering the Yakuza family.
And it's just, I can't
explain why I like it.
It's just kind of cool.
And like a lot of the sound
clips are just really iconic.
The music is really iconic.
You'll hear it sampled
a lot in Japanese rap.
It's just really neat.
And there's a lot of blood.
It was one of the like most prominent,
I think Yakuza films made in Japan.
There's five of them.
I haven't watched the last one,
but I've been slowly working through them.
I found them on Amazon
with English subtitles.
There was only one copy
in the world and I got it.
- Oh wow.
So it wasn't even streamed,
it was like physical media.
Holy shit.
That's how you know it's like underground.
- [Connor] OG.
- How did you find that?
- I was recommended it by a friend
who really likes Japanese movies.
And I was like, "Ah, I
should check it out."
And I really liked it.
- When was the last time
you bought physical media?
- Mother Knows Breast.
- Bought it to watch it.
- [Connor] I watched it.
- You've watched?
You've actually put it in?
I don't have a DVD player.
- [Garnt] That's what I thought.
- Do you have a DVD player?
- No, but a PlayStation works just fine.
- I can't remember the last
time I brought like a DVD
or a Blu-ray that I actually watched.
I've even bought like
anime blue-rays and DVDs,
but just like, that's just
so I can own them physically.
- Even if I bought it, I
ain't putting that shit in.
You know how annoying it is getting up,
bending down, putting it in, fuck.
- Dude, I can just chromecast this.
- My poor knees.
- I'm an old man now.
Oh so I'm a child now, but
I was an old man one time.
And that was very difficult.
- You're an old man
stuck in a child's body.
- I am, I am.
I just want to do everything digitally.
It's so much easier.
- I mean that's why it's
become a dying medium.
- That's why you like,
I mean, forget DVDs.
You don't watch anything
that's not on Netflix now.
- You know what sucks is that,
everything good is unlike
Hulu and HBO and I'm like,
we don't have that shit.
It's so unfair.
I'm like, I don't know how to do this.
Please help me, I want HBO.
Everything seems to be on HBO.
- Oh, I mean a lot of
the good shows, I'd say
like a lot of the
critically acclaimed shows
seems to be on HBO.
- You can't get it outside of America.
- Is this where you select
a sponsorship, perhaps?
- Actually funny thing.
A lot of HBO shows and a lot
of TV shows are available
on YouTube to buy, but I've noticed like..
'Cause I've watched "Chernobyl"
and I watched that on YouTube.
- I watched on Amazon Prime.
- Oh, it's on Amazon Prime, yeah?
- Yeah, I watched on Amazon Prime.
- Okay, but that's probably
like the last amazing live action TV show
that I've probably got into.
- [Connor] Yeah, I love that.
- Yeah, fucking amazing.
- You guys just realize sometimes
how things have developed
with like anime and
Japanese culture in general
because I remember a
time when I was younger
and I had to beg momma
Maury to drive me 40 minutes
to the only small anime
store in our state.
- The fact that you
even had an anime store-
- Yeah, you're probably
just showing (laughing).
- Porkie was $6
and I remember saving up all
what little allowance I could.
- Porkie, oh my God.
- You think that was a Romane?
- [Mori] Yeah, with a Romane, it was $6.
- I don't know Vermont gone,
but like I came into anime
it was kind of becoming more globalized
and the internet was kind
of kicking into full force.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And yeah, even back then, it was like,
you couldn't get anything like nothing.
- You didn't live through the dog age.
- No, all I could get was like
the worst I had to deal with.
It was like, you give GX Espanol part one.
That was like the worst
I had to deal with,
but I could still get it, I can get it.
- No, I mean, we could also get it as well
it just was a lot harder to find.
We had to put more work into
it other than just streaming.
I feel like made anime just like
kinda like it made anime fucking
way more accessible because
even back in my day,
I still bought DVDs whenever I could.
But then once streaming became a thing,
I just stopped buying DVDs at all.
And yeah, it is certainly weird
to see anime become way more
fucking popular nowadays,
even though none of us
watch it anymore (laughing).
Right, shawty?
- Yeah.
The more popular anime has
become, the less I've watched.
- Do you watch much anime now, Calli?
- I mean, to be honest,
I feel like all the anime
I'm really interested in
is older stuff that I get recommended.
For example, "Kaiji" and "Baki",
I've been really into.
- "Baki"?
- [Garnt] Hell yeah.
- [Mori] Too much pleasure I just-
- Are you caught up on the anime?
- No, that is the only one
that I've been slowly watching
'cause I don't want it to end.
So like day by day watching
an episode, nice and slow.
- It's so good, I love that.
- I still want to watch in anime.
- What party you want it, I want to ask?
- Let's see, what part did we stop off at?
Let me think,
'cause I've been watching it with a friend
who is also a big fan
and we've been watching
like at the same time,
like overseas, completely
separated from each other.
Let me see which part where we at.
- What was the last thing that happened?
- What was the most iconic
thing that happened?
- I mean, every episode.
(all laughing)
- I think "Baki" officially
challenged his father,
I think was the last thing
that happened that I saw.
I'm like trying to not-
- Did it like 10 times?
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
- Do you realize how little
that narrows us down?
- It's a new season, a new season.
- [Joey] Oh, she's at three?
- Yeah, I have to admit-
- Oh, its your pretty father?
- Yeah, when I started watching "Baki"
I actually challenged myself
and I didn't watch it
with English subtitles
I watched it completely Japanese
with Japanese only subtitles.
And I did not figure out
that Baki's dad was who he is
until I felt so ashamed.
I was like, wow
three years self study Japanese
and I can't even figure that out.
- I feel you, I feel you
'cause sometimes like,
do you watch all anime unsubs now then?
Or do you watch like
some sub, some unsubbed?
- Ah, it depends.
Usually what I'll do is if
it's one that I've seen before,
I'll watch it without subtitles.
But I mean, I do watch it with subtitles,
with the Japanese subtitles.
So I at least get the Kanji
to like help me out if I can't really hear
how something's pronounced.
- [Connor] Yeah, Kanji helps a lot.
- Yeah.
If there's like something
you don't understand,
you like rewind as well
and like, just to see if-
- That sounds like a nightmare.
- It is a nightmare.
- That's how you learn.
You're not watching it in the same way
that you're watching to enjoy anymore.
It is a learning experience,
- Study material.
- Yeah. It is study material.
I mean, in terms of study material,
I can think of worse
study material than anime,
but-
- For sure.
- It's the sacrifice you have
to make, I guess, to make.
- That's why you got to like use
like as soon as you've already seen
and like a familiar with, right.
- It's not really bad
'cause like when I was hanging out
with some Japanese friends
and everyone was watching "Kaiji"
and I watched it too.
And of course there were
no English subtitles.
So I was watching and I recall going home
and going on Wikipedia and
looking up what happened.
- I mean, there are some shows
that are easier to follow than others.
I can barely follow the rules
of what happened is happening
in "Kaiji", in English,
let alone in another language.
- Sure, I mean, there's
"Peppa Pig", plot lines, man.
Those things are fucking complex, man.
Very complex.
- Obviously you laugh
but yeah, I took lady bed's advice
and I started watching
"Peppa Pig" in Japanese.
And I could tell my Japanese was improving
by how much of "Peppa
Pig" I could understand.
I don't know, it got to a point
where I could understand 80%,
80 to 90% of "Peppa Pig".
And that was like, that was
the first time I felt, holy shit
I'm actually making fucking progress.
- Like veins off with his hand power.
Oh, this is power!
- Oh shit, "Peppa Pig" is
a good shot (laughing).
- And then I graduated to
normal anime after that.
And even then there are some anime
you have to be very selective
in the anime you watch,
if you want to treat
anime as a study material,
'cause some things are just like,
just like so far beyond your level.
- "Baki" seems like a hard one to choose.
- Yeah, because I feel like
"Baki" would be pretty hard
because there's so much explanation
of like boys happening on screen
and like the backstory and stuff.
- Trust me, I read the manga
and sometimes I have
to like, double-take me
like what the fuck does that mean?
I'm pretty sure I'm
fluent in this language
but it doesn't look like my language.
- Yeah, it's like sometimes "Baki"
is like a visual storytelling medium.
And then sometimes it's really not.
- Sometimes it's a novel.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Exactly.
I remember where I was,
we just left the prison.
Please don't spoil it for me.
Please check, please, I beg
of you, don't spoil it for me.
We also do fake spoilers in the chat.
- Did you say chat? (laughing)
- No, because they were watching.
- Static chat.
- Listen, you've got some time now,
soon this episode areas to finish.
- The marathons and I'm on it
because we do fake spoilers in my chat.
So, you can't trust anyone
what anyone's saying.
So I say guys throw
out some fake spoilers.
So people who are putting out
real spoilers could be lying.
We don't know, that's
how I protect my chat.
- "Baki" is one of those shows
where you could give out a real spoil
and you'd be like, I
guess that's what happens.
(Mori laughs)
- We gave out a bunch last step.
So it actually-
- We literally just talked about "Baki"
so it wasn't planned at all
that we'd mentioned "Baki" again.
- Yeah.
- But thank you very much
for building on what we said.
- Please go and watch "Baki."
- [Joey] Watch "Baki."
- Please I beg you.
- It is now VTuber approved.
- [Joey] Exactly, Grim
Reaper, watch "Baki".
- I know you guys are here too,
because I know I have a lot of fans of me
who literally come to my stream
and say, I came here from Trash Taste.
A lot of deadbeats whose names I see over
and over and over again,
who are always there.
I'm really thankful to you guys.
Thank you so much for bringing
me so many cool deadbeats.
- Of course.
- Oh, you came on, man.
I just sat here and spoke.
- I just sat here and ask you questions.
- How has it been since that episode
and how has life been in
Japan over the last year?
- Oh man, interestingly enough,
and I hate to say it it's
been a little sad only
because I really haven't
gotten out of the house much
and like, I can't figure out if it's,
because of the situation the world is in
or because now I'm
officially a workaholic.
So I can't figure it out.
- I think I know which
is the answer to that one
if I had to say just to take a guess.
- [Joey] Say both just the distracted one.
- Yeah, it's probably just
like a combination of both.
- Definitely.
- I'm also a workaholic
so I know it's the second one.
- Oh man, how I did in front of everyone?
(all laughing)
We are all working.
- That's how it is, I even got married.
- I remember when kind
of wasn't a workaholic
and then he discovered streaming
and then that was like the spare time
that he had is now like
dedicated to streaming.
- It turns out when you don't
really enjoy what you're making,
it's really easy to like, not do it,
but when you enjoy it, it's
really hard to not do it.
- [Garnt] Yeah, it's kind of like-
- Fast. (laughing)
- Spinning balls, bro.
- Imagine you're enjoying your job.
- Yeah, crazy, man.
(Joey laughing)
I just thought a job was
something that you don't enjoy,
but you do because you have to do it
because everyone does it.
That's what my perception of jobs was
when I was growing up.
- Yeah.
- I worked at McDonald's for fuck sake.
You think I like that?
I hated that.
- Wanna know where I worked?
- [Connor] Where?
- Where?
(Garnt laughs)
- Remind me.
- Where?
- Remind me, Calli, do you
know where I worked before?
- I think I do.
- Remind me again.
- I think I remember.
- So I worked at the
BBC before (laughing).
- Oh, fucking, man.
- That's right.
I was like ABC, no?
(all laughing)
- [Joey] Something like that.
- That's the American company.
- Yeah, that's right.
- You must've loved it
'cause you never shut up about it.
- I never shut up about
it 'cause I hated it.
(all laughing)
- I don't bring a McDonald's
every goddam week.
I love that people repost clips of you
from like years ago now
talking about you used to work at BBC.
- Yeah, before it was a meme.
Yeah, before it was a meme (laughing).
- On God's business card
it actually says, we
used to work at the BBC.
- Did it actually?
(all laughing)
- It says if I wouldn't
put a post you'll do that.
- Thanks BBC employee.
- Yeah.
- For the record, he's just talking shit.
- Certified BBC employee.
- Oh, come on, my god, Calli (chuckles).
- So like on the vein of that,
do you probably see this as a job
or is it just something
that you enjoy so much
that it doesn't feel like a job
and it's just so easy to do?
- That's a really good question.
I mean, all before
this, I was also working
for example, service jobs.
There was never a point in my life
where I wasn't working a job
was usually a job I didn't like,
but I was saving up money, to go to Japan.
And even when I started
doing sites swinging lessons,
that was also something that I had
a hard time with every day,
waking up and feeling like
going through the same thing.
Like it wasn't satisfying to me.
I think that there are plenty of people
that can work desk jobs and office jobs
that love it and have a great time.
Or even if they don't love it,
they're fine enough with it to go home
and just have a drink
and watch your content
that's perfectly fine.
- I was under the impression
that people just wanted to work
and then they did it just
so that they could like
play games in the evening.
That's what I thought jobs
were when I was growing.
- I think there is jobs for most people.
- Yeah, that's what I thought.
- [Garnt] I know.
- That's why then when I was doing YouTube
and that was sometime
I wasn't enjoying it,
there's some posts I didn't enjoy.
I was like, oh, this is
normal, it's a normal job.
But now I really like, it I'm addicted.
- Yeah, which is why-
- For me it comes in waves.
It depends on whether you're working,
whether you enjoy what
you're working on or not.
Sometimes if you're really
passionate about it,
it's just easy to do.
And when you're not enjoying
it, then it is a grind.
- That's right.
- That's the sacrifice that we make
for being in very lucky positions.
- We're lucky.
- Yeah.
- But I will say it's okay
to not have a passion.
I just want to put that out there.
It's fine to not have one.
I think it's perfectly fine to just
do your job that you hopefully don't hate.
If you hate it, I think you should stop it
and find a job that you
don't hate at the very least.
And then go home and just do your hobby.
Do what makes you happy,
I think that's great.
But if you do have a passion, then I think
it's nice to at least give it a try
to try to get it
and if it doesn't work
out, it doesn't work out.
- Unfortunately as well,
most of the time hobbies or passions,
aren't monetizable passions.
- But when you do start to monetize it,
it stops becoming your hobby.
- Yeah, remember it was at the time now.
I think, cause obviously
you're surrounded in media,
especially by people who are
passionate about something
'cause I've been there.
You don't get that by
not being passionate.
So I definitely agree
that this will give you this false sense
of everyone has to have a passion, right?
- Right.
And also I feel like I
see a lot of interviews
that say things like
from people, for example,
like us who have been very
successful at what we do
I see a lot of people
say over and over again,
just go for your dream, you can do it.
If you really believe and work super hard,
I know that I've said something
like that in the past,
but I want to very quickly correct myself.
(all laughing)
- Dreams are alive.
- Here's the thing-
- Back peddle, back peddle,
back peddle, back peddle.
- You need to two things,
you got to realize that
you're taking a risk
you're making a gamble
because you need two things.
You need to work hard and you
need to be extremely lucky
and you need to have both of them.
You can't just have one,
you gotta have both.
But the problem is if you
don't work extremely hard,
then there's no chance.
There's no chance to ever happen.
- And it's scary to take that
chance in your life sometimes
because some people just
don't have a safety net.
And so they fucking Yolo
everything into this passion.
And I'm just like, I couldn't do that.
I respect anyone who
has the guts to do that.
Like for me, like I had to save up
for like a year's worth of wages
that I would could live comfortably on
before I was even comfortable quitting
to try and do YouTube.
- Could have been three more videos.
- Yeah, I know.
(all laughing)
- We never know.
- There are three last videos
that could have made it that year.
I'm sorry, Calli.
- But I think that even the fact
that you had the balls to do that
is quite an admirable
because I'm sure there's a lot
of people who want to like,
get into either what we do
or some kind of creative field
that might have a year,
five years, 10 years
with the savings
and they could just never
take that first and forward.
So I think just doing that,
like, for me, it's like,
I was still at school
when I started this whole thing.
So, I had that safety net all like, well,
if it doesn't work out,
I'll just get my degree,
get a fucking job.
- Yeah, it's also difficult
I feel like when you're talking
to other people who are successful
in that particular field,
you almost get this
like not survivor bias,
but like everyone's done it.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So how do you get a actual view
the whole picture of
the whole playing field
if your only perspective is from talking
to people who've made it?
Sometimes I think like, huh,
but then you can't go to someone like,
Hey, you've been tries for
15 years and you just failed.
Hey, can I talk to you for a moment?
Can you figure out what's going on?
You can't do that.
- Remember that traumatic time
where you try to make it and you didn't?
It's always about that?
- It's not always like that
where people will just do it forever.
Like people give up for many
reasons, people just stop.
They don't necessarily give up
but there's a lot of like lot of factors
that come into play.
But also I do think that
sometimes I'm like, huh,
maybe I'm just talking to other people
who've just made it too much.
And I feel like I can't
actually get a good perspective
of what it takes.
- Yeah, I mean, I get that
and I think that we've just
talked to enough people
where you see certain patterns
like everyone has a different path.
Not everyone has exactly the same path,
but you've noticed certain
patterns that keep cropping up.
And you're like, I kind
of did that as well.
And I'm just like...
'Cause I thought that at the beginning,
there is nothing you can do
to like guarantee success.
And there is nothing you can do
to guarantee success in our fields,
but there are certainly things you can do
to increase your chances.
- [Connor] Yeah, true.
- And I feel like that just
comes with knowledge, right?
That just comes with
just the trial and error
and just like what Calli's experience,
where you start off, you're new,
you don't know what you're
doing and then eventually
you do it enough
and then you're able
to get the opportunity
to see what works and what doesn't.
And obviously we've all been very lucky
as you say, as Calli said, you need luck
to succeed in this field,
but there are other things you can do
that can increase your
chances of success as well.
So there's no guarantees,
but there is ways I think
that you can increase your chances.
- What do you think
you would be doing now,
if you want to report
if it never happened?
- Man, to be honest with you though,
I genuinely answering 100%
honest, I'd still be trying.
- Yeah.
- I'd still be trying
to make it with music.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I just don't think I would've given up
because I don't know what else to do.
See, that's the other thing, guys,
you got to recognize that it's a gamble,
so you better like it.
You better really, really love it.
So that even if you don't quote
unquote, pop off or succeed,
you love like every second of doing it,
I think is the most important.
Back when I first came on the podcast,
I feel like I didn't fully grasp it yet.
I was so kind of like, whoa,
I'm suddenly doing really well,
way better than I've ever been in my life.
This is because I worked
hard, I just worked so hard.
- I remember you coming on
and you were so like bright-eyed
and it just like so optimistic.
(all laughing)
- Now you're damn inside.
- I mean, that's why I
had to like step back
for a minute though, and
correct myself and say,
I was a little conceited back then.
Wasn't fully aware of what I was doing,
but of course, once you change your stance
on something on the
internet, you're a hypocrite.
So that's just kinda how it goes.
- Yeah, there's no change.
- When did like start to hit you
of like, oh, this is what
the life is like, oh?
- Let me see.
That's another really good question.
You guys got some bangers today.
- That's right, we're interrogating you.
- I'm just genuinely curious.
- Here's the grinding.
Let me see.
It must have been
at the a million subscriber
endurance stream.
I think that was when it really hit me.
Things are going to be
extra different now on.
Wow, that was when we were
really popping off though.
Like everyone was
exploding every single day
with new subs and new members
and that was like the prime,
and that was when it really
hit me like, oh, wow,
this is the craziest thing
I've ever done in my existence.
And I'm extremely lucky.
- Yeah.
- Wow, and that was kind
of when I changed my stance
on, oh, you just need to
work hard to get far in life.
I realized now that's a little conceited
to say that it's not
true, it's not real life.
- Do you feel that mentioning
that you said that there
was like a big pop off on it
and explosion, do you feel like
the scene has changed a bit
of the way the viewers
interact changed over the year?
'Cause I feel like the peak of it
is kind of all at the high
peak at like the newness of it.
It's kind of died down a little.
- Yeah, I think it's okay to admit
that it kind of died down a lot, actually.
The market is really saturated right now.
- Yeah, you don't say.
- First time (laughing).
- That is the truth.
Tat is the plain truth of it all.
There are a lot of people
interested in VTubing.
Now it has gotten really big.
A lot of people have come in
and also a lot of people have left.
A lot of people have tried
it out for several months
and realized it's not for them
all the power to them, good for them
but that's just kind
of like how it's gone.
That's how it goes with anything.
You realize you're into
something, you stick with it.
You realize it's not
your thing, you drop out
and that's cool.
But that's why there's been a
bit of like a wave, I think.
And I think a lot of
people have seen VTubers.
They kind of know what they are,
especially in like the
anime sphere, I guess.
And I feel like that's just
how things go sometimes.
The longevity of something,
I hope that people continue doing this.
I hope this keeps being something fun
that everyone can enjoy.
- I think VTube was going
to be around for the future.
'Cause I feel like, yeah,
we've had our popularity peak,
especially in the English community
and now it is much more saturated
but I don't think it's like died down.
I think it's more like
it's just leveled off.
- It's plateaud.
- Plateaud, that was the
word I was looking for.
Thank you gentlemen.
Did you learn that from Duolingo?
(all laughing)
- People are coming up
with new ideas every day
and amazing new technology
some of these, ND VTubers with 3D
that they're doing is like mind blowing.
- [Connor] Absolutely.
- And I think it's going to
keep evolving in its own way.
And I'm really excited to see that.
- Do you ever feel like the pressure
to have to keep up to like, keep relevant
as the word, every YouTuber fucking loves?
- Staying relevant.
Oh man, I mean, I think
that's a worry for everyone.
And if they say it isn't
then they're lying straight to your face.
At least is a teeny tiny
bit, just a little bit,
especially when it's your job,
you do worry about things like that.
But I feel like my interest
in numbers drastically waned
after, like, I feel like,
a lot of the core fan base
came in and we still get
new deadbeats all the time.
Always very welcome and opening to them.
But it's like, I stopped caring
as much about the number situation
when I started to
genuinely enjoy streaming
and making music, as me.
- Yeah.
- Right. Right.
Is it ever like a frustrating
because we kind of in the same thing,
but we're all like our own unique kind
of channel and whatnot.
Is there ever like a frustrating thing
'cause you obviously all the Vtube
has come in as one package,
it's like, this is the generation.
How do you make sure
that there's not this kind of weird sense
of competition amongst fellow VTubers?
Cause you're all kind of the same thing.
I mean, you're not the same,
but you're the same
target audience, right?
Joey talks about manga anime
and I might go and do something silly,
gone so my fate, it's
totally different audience,
even though we all kind of
in the same market, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- With VTubing, I always wonder
how do you like stop that from happening
like a competition like that?
- It's hard for me to speak on behalf
of the entire VTuber community.
- Yeah, yeah.
- As much as I support
and love, like the work
of what Indies are doing,
I don't have enough energy in my life
to go socialize with many outside of holo,
which I think is a shame
and I wish I could,
but it's kind of difficult to do.
So I can really only speak about
what I've seen within holo,
but I just feel like somehow
there was some kind of magic involved
in the selection process
where they chose people
that we just don't really get
extra jealous of each other.
I mean, at least this is me
saying, from my perspective,
I don't know what's going
through the other side.
(all laughing)
I can't speak on their behalf,
but I can say for me genuinely,
the people that they chose,
I look at them and I just
want to see them succeed.
And I feel like part of me is questioning
like, well, shouldn't you be wanting
to be better than X and so-and-so,
but I just can't parse that feeling.
I just don't feel it, that is the truth.
I mean, of course there's
me wanting to be my best,
but I guess here's a good example
I can give you from my past.
My first really, really close friend ever
was a friend that I met in middle school,
who was the new kid.
She moved to my city.
I had no friends in that school.
It was not great, but this new kid came
and she was drawing, she
had how to draw manga book.
- Hell yeah.
- And I had been trying
to figure out like,
what is that art style called?
Because I didn't know
where to search for it.
I was young, I had no idea.
And so she explained it to me.
She opened up the whole world to me
and she let me borrow it.
And that was when I started drawing.
And I came to school the next day
and people were like, wow,
you can draw really well,
you both are really good.
Some people were saying, Calli,
you're maybe a little better.
And I was like, no, that's not true.
But that was the feeling that I got
of, I can do something, and be good at it.
And people are looking at what I'm doing
and then of course my friend
was also like, oh, hell yeah,
let's learn together.
And we became friendly
rivals in that, like,
we were always kind of working
alongside each other drawing.
And like, maybe you show
your friend a picture,
you drew, Hey, this is
my original character.
Oh, cool, here's mine.
And like, you're still friends,
but there's this feeling of,
I got to keep up with this person.
And as I started being involved
in more art communities,
as I grew older and met friends
on the internet, et cetera,
we all were still cool and
friends with each other,
but seeing other's hard work made us want
to keep up that kind of thing.
So-and-so drew this wall.
I want to try doing that.
Let me see how I can do.
So it's not like an outright
feeling of jealousy,
but it's a feeling of wanting to like,
make yourself better to keep up, I guess.
And it's like friendly competition, just-
- That's good, it sounds very healthy.
- Yeah. That's how it
was for me, personally.
So no bad feelings.
- That's a very good answer.
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
- That was most wholesome answer to all.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- I was like, waiting for
the blood to be spilled.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
- And then I'd stabbed her with the pan.
(all laughing)
- [Mori] That's a habit-
- Who's going now?
(all laughing)
- And a close group of friends
that kind of like healthy
competition can form, I think
instead of like a wide group
of people competing together,
like a death game,
for example, death games
on the mind, sorry guys.
- I was going to say back
when the death games.
- But if it's like a
small group of friends,
it's really easy to foster,
like a healthy competition.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I think it's that whole mentality
that a lot of people still struggle
to understand of like,
if one person succeeds,
then the rest can also come up.
It's kind of mentality.
And I feel that like
at least only YouTubers
and stuff like that, and probably,
in the VTuber community as well,
where it's like,
if one VTuber succeeds,
then everyone in that same genre
can also kind of rise up
together as a community.
And I feel, especially
like a lot of the smaller creators
still don't quite understand that yet,
I think in my eyes like where it's like,
no, I need to be better than this person.
- Normally the biggest channel
that I needed genre is an
indication of the size.
- The cap of the-
- It's normally a good way.
So if someone at the top is blowing up,
that's normally a good thing.
- [Garnt] Yeah exactly.
- It's a trickle down.
- Like I wouldn't have
come back to YouTube
if I didn't see Joey blowing up
'cause I thought when I quit YouTube,
I'd like reach the ceiling.
- I need my crown back.
(all laughing)
I was the Guinea pig.
It's a metaphor.
- 'Cause I was just like,
I thought that I had reached the ceiling
of anime content on YouTube
and at the time I had,
because anime just wasn't as popular.
So I'm just like-
- And then I was like Arrow boy.
(all laughing)
- I completed YouTube.
- I came back for YouTube too (laughing).
- The "Sequel" (laughing),
long awaited "Sequel."
You were saying, Calli?
- No, you're good, you're good.
I was thinking like personally,
I think the most healthy way
to like compete in general though,
isn't to think about who
you're going to go past,
but beating the you of yesterday.
So inspirational hashtag.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Pony tail.
- [Connor] Just inspiration things.
- - [Joey] Hash tag, motivated.
- Sounds like I've seen now "Baki."
(all laughing)
- You're only as good as how
many times you've had sex.
That's a "Baki."
(all laughing)
- That's right.
But I mean, if you think about it though,
there is some truth to it.
As long as you are doing
better than your past self,
as long as I'm doing better
than past me, I feel good.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. I mean, it's very
easy to compare yourself
to others and then hold
yourself to some standards.
You don't want to be the
gig of chat, but we count.
- Yeah, would you have any advice
to up-and-coming VTubers?
Now they've had like a year of experience.
- You're the senpai right now.
- Let's see, maybe I'll pass along
some advice that my
senpai had given to me,
never stop doing new things,
keep trying new stuff
and that's the only way to be, I think,
is to keep pushing the boundaries
and see what kind of wonderful
stuff can come from this.
I think that's my advice to you guys,
just passing on what I've been told.
- Oh yeah.
I mean, I'd say that's good advice
for like any content
creators, VTuber or nodes.
(screen whooshing)
Do you feel sometimes that
you would have an easier time
being like, say an indie VTuber,
without having to like
worry about management
and things like that?
- That's right.
Well, the way that I
kind of view it is yeah
there are restrictions
and for the most part,
I get why they're in place.
Right here, right now with me as I am,
I'm happy to kind of
like work around things.
For example, there are games
that I can always stream
and I can't do it at all actually.
And that's fine.
A lot of them are ones that I like a lot,
but at the end of the day, like I said,
I've been trying to be
more positive recently.
So the way that I think
about it is, you know what?
Out of this list, I will
choose the ones that I like
and I will have fun with them.
And I think that's the
best way to go about it
because you know, life is
long, for the most part-
- Password? (laughing).
- Because of me, it's not
as long as it could be.
However, do a lot of things in your life
and your existence.
One life ends, one begins, et cetera
that's how it was for me a long time ago.
So you never know what
the future will hold.
But right now with me
as I am, just the Mori
in front of you,
I can find workarounds
and ways to still have fun
with the restrictions that are in place.
And I think that that's kind
of the attitude to have,
if you're going to go into this
and join a big company, like hololive.
You kind of work with it-
- Is it something you were expecting
the restrictions or was
this kind of a shock?
- I think in the beginning
I thought that it would
be a bit different.
However, I don't think,
like I mentioned before,
none of us knew how big
this was going to be.
- Yeah.
- And when that happens,
things kind of change a bit.
- Right, when there's more money involved.
- [Mori] Yeah.
- More people get involved.
- Imagine, just imagine.
- To have a capitalism.
- Business folks, man.
(all laughing)
- Things go rough.
- [Connor] When stuff blows up,
everyone wants to take credit for it.
- That's how things are shawty.
(all laughing)
- We live in a society.
- We (chuckles)-
- Are trying to keep this politics free.
Thank you very much.
- [Connor] Society.
- Yeah, society.
- Just try and stay positive.
- What are some of the top ideas
that you would want to do
if like, you have no restrictions at all?
- Oh man, it's mostly games to be honest,
that I think about collabs
that I'd want to do with people
that just can't realistically happen.
And it's like, there's
not just like protest
from my side, either from management,
but also from people
who watch me and like,
I pay attention to that kind of stuff.
They don't let it completely influence me,
but like I do look at it and try
to, factor in as much as I can see,
this is why I have like no energy,
because there's so much
going on in my brain
and I love you so much.
- So you pay attention to what games
the chat wants you to play?
- I do, but that's
because I genuinely want
everyone to have a good time.
And if I see the same thing
happen over and over again,
it gets in my mind.
But again, it goes back to the point
where I said, every single nice thing
that said to you, that's a critique
is not necessarily going to
help you or be helpful to you.
So I just try to keep that in mind
and stay open-minded the whole time.
But it's mostly just games and collabs
that I wish I could do
that I kind of realistically can't,
but it doesn't mean that
they'll never, ever happen
ever in the history of ever
it's just not like this.
- Yeah.
- And I think that's fine, personally.
- Thank you for letting Calli
come back on Trash Taste.
Thank you very much.
- Happy to be here.
- [Connor] Appreciated.
- So many things on Trash Taste.
And I certainly am happy
to be a guest here.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, thank you so much.
- Speaking of future though,
what's in the future of Calli, recently?
- There's a lot of ideas that I have,
especially in terms of
original song a month,
that's still a thing that's happening.
I've got a big, big collab song coming out
with a fellow member of EN,
I think I've talked about this.
I don't know how much
of this will be teased
by the time that this comes out,
but I hope you guys are looking
forward to it, it is huge.
And we're working with a huge producer,
like the likes of which I never thought
I'd be able to work with, so.
- Dj Khaleed.
(all laughing)
- Could you imagine?
- A guy who wrote the Pokemon Rap?
(all laughing)
- Damn, very met, Calli (laughing).
- I'm very excited to see you.
- Yeah, I hope that
you guys will enjoy it.
We've been working really hard on it
and yeah, in general, I'm just trying
to prepare for another
big release someday.
And also in my crystal ball,
we've got a possibility
I'd really like to do
a world tour someday.
- [Both] Ooh!
- That would be hype.
- [Joey] Yeah, that would be hard.
- I mean, definitely at some point
while I'm doing this,
hopefully we will get a
world to our fingers crossed.
- The board needs to open up first
before we can have a well tour.
But I said the world-
- The world can't heal until Calli
goes to every country,
that's not possible.
(all laughing)
- Also the grim Reaper has to heal you.
- The healing has not been done yet, God,
it hasn't happened.
- That's real to me.
Aside from that though, in
the more immediate future,
we have our anime NYC,
happening on November 20th,
that's when we have a booth day.
- Joey chat a yeah.
- [All] Yeah!
- That's it.
We have a booth happening.
- It's nice to see you
that's a whiteboard
being used for something
other than like saying incest.
(all laughing)
- Actual information.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, well, at anime NYC,
we have a booth, a holo booth
but at that same place, we
have a collab popping off.
I'm sure you guys have seen by now.
Oh, with OMOCAT who is designing clothes
for all of us in holoEN
Myth right now and so
that is extremely exciting
'cause I've been a big fan of OMOCAT
for years and years and years,
it's like a dream collab.
- OMOCAT is like OGs.
- [Mori] Yeah.
- Oh Yeah.
- Really amazing, amazing work.
And I'm also the creator of Aomori,
I played that game on stream.
It was a long stream.
- Yeah, okay.
- One of my favorite endurance
streams of all times.
So yeah, I'm just really glad
that we got to work with all of them
and yeah, it's just really cool.
I'm excited for you guys
to see the clothes, they're awesome.
Please buy them, please wear them
and go check out the booth.
- Yeah, it sounds like you've got
a lot of exciting things coming up.
- Yeah, there's a lot going on.
- Stacked schedule, TM.
- Yeah, right (laughing).
- Even now, there's still a
lot of fun stuff going on,
which is a relief that after a year
it's not like things are
slowing down or anything.
No, we've still got a lot going on.
And you guys haven't seen everything
that Myth or even EN has cooked
up just yet, so stay tuned.
- I have a feeling you'll
continue to be very busy.
- Yeah, it just seems
like it's speeding up.
- I was just like, maybe you'll find
some free time coming up.
Oh, the world's opening back,
oh, fuck me, oh man (laughing).
- Rip six hours.
- Rip six hours (laughing).
It's like, where do I find slime?
Well, sleep, it's only like six hours.
- Can I work while I sleep?
(all laughing)
I got to figure that out.
- That's why you were
talking in your sleep before
planning your next moves.
- It's like planning my next sleep.
- Why am I screaming in my sleep?
(Joey laughing)
What's going on, man?
- I guess before we end things off,
I do have a question for you
'cause you didn't give me a shit
about pizza gross last time.
- I did.
- So I got to ask,
boneless chicken or in-bone chicken?
- Boneless.
(Joey screams)
- That's what I'm talking about.
- I'm done guys, thanks for coming
to this episode of Trash Taste.
- It's just the most obvious.
- I would shake your hand,
but we're on a different virtual plane.
- Exactly, I am in another dimension.
So it's kind of rough, but-
- Congratulations.
- Virtual high five for that one.
- Gone is now the fourth
member of Trash Taste.
Garnt is now the fo member of Trash Taste.
- I'm going to ask this
every time a guest comes on,
I'm going to find one fucking
person who is on my side.
- Tell me why boneless
is better than bone?
- Oh, boneless wides better than bone
and cause bones are annoying.
- [Connor] Exactly.
- I mean, I don't want
to eat around the bone-
- It's worth the taste,
it's worth the taste.
- You eat all the bone
and you starting to see
all the little veins
and like dark spots pop out, it's nasty.
I don't want to eat the chicken anymore.
- I think you just stop
asking that question
unless you want to get
owned every other time.
- No, I'm going to find a
fellow brother or sister.
Someone is going to come
here and back me up.
(all laughing)
One day you know who you are.
You're out there right now.
I'm waiting, I'm waiting for that time.
- POV, your client.
- You're going to need this.
You need this (laughing).
- [Joey] My God.
- I'm no longer a VTuber fan now.
(all laughing)
- Wait a minute, hold on, no.
- Friendship of VTuber, over.
(all laughing)
Bone chicken is my best friend.
- Oh my God.
- Go and eat your savage.
- [Mori] I can't eat bone and-
- I can't, I just don't want to,
I'd prefer boneless
'cause I'm not an animal.
- Don't mean you can eat bone
and it's not that much of an effort.
- If I got like 50 wet wipes on hand
yeah, we can talk about doing it,
but I don't want it.
- Let's let's not start this.
- Well, thanks for joining us.
- Add another hour of the podcast.
Of course, I'm always happy to
come hang out with you guys.
And it's been a blast, thank you.
- Thank you very much for coming back on.
- Yeah, of course, any time.
- Of course we shouldn't tell you this,
but a link in the description below
to go and check out Calli
and all the stuff you guys already know.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, coming out, you'll like.
- We're premiering this episode again-
- We get in the super chats already.
- We're getting to super chats.
- I completely forgot about that.
- [Connor] Yeah, I guess we're familiar.
- I thought you're super
chest right now (laughing).
- This is the last chance.
- Last chance because
the patrons are here now.
(all laughing)
That's where the episode ends.
- [Mori] Oh, God.
- Don't throw super chats,
but hey, if you enjoyed this show-
- You gonna say, don't do it.
- Yet, no.
- Don't give this manga,
don't give this money.
- Don't give us the money.
- Now my least favorite
color is red, so don't.
(Garnt and Mori laughs)
I don't wanna see at all.
- Don't get me wrong, I do appreciate it.
But there is a common theme
even when I'm in other streams,
the more that they say no, don't,
the more that people get real rambunctious
and see it as a challenge.
- Yes please, I hate it.
- Is that a VTuber life hacker,
I just heard right there? (chuckles).
- I can't stand colors.
Just say no, just say no.
- I hate money.
- But if you like to support the show
then make sure to go-
- Don't donate to our Patreon.
Don't don't go to our Patreon.
Look at these guys, look at this Patreon
she don't want to be one
of these people, okay?
Especially this guy, don't be that guy.
- This one is a law
supporter, but come on.
- I thought it was our super chat.
(all laughing)
- [Mori] Oh, my God.
- Can I see his name right
here on the super chat? No.
- I'm sorry, we're
terrible people, I'm sorry.
We didn't have the show.
- Yeah, but if you would
like to support the show
then make show to go to our page
on patreon.com/trashtaste
also follow us on Twitter.
Send us your memes on the sub cyber
and if you had our face,
listen to us on Spotify
and yeah, thanks for coming on, Calli.
- Of course, anytime,
thanks for having me.
- It's been great just seeing you
grow in the last year.
- Thank you.
- It's been awesome seeing you
just like fucking become really confident
as a streamer and just a
content creator in general.
And now I feel like I remember
the first you coming on,
it did feel like yeah,
you were very bright-eyed,
you were very optimistic.
And now I feel like we have
a lot more in common (laughing).
- That's a little real with you.
Really realistic.
- I could tell the exact moment
when you stopped giving a
fuck about what people thought
and just enjoy doing your own thing.
- That's a good vibe, it's a good sign.
- It's like a rite of
passage as a content creator.
- I suppose.
- So join us, you've made it, join us.
- Well, the same could
be said for you guys.
You guys have definitely
popped off as well.
This new place is amazing.
- Oh yeah (laughing).
- Thank you for inviting me too.
- I'm glad you didn't have
to go over the trip hazard this time.
- All right.
- You actually got to sit
in the guest seat this time.
- [Joey] Yeah, exactly.
- Not like this corner, which was-
- Technology is evolving.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly we've
also evolved for the time,
but yeah, that's been this
episode of Trash Taste.
I hope you enjoyed the episode.
See you guys next week.
- I guess we should say peace, right?
- Yeah, we've got to
say peace, super loud.
All right, ready?
Three, two, one,
- [All] Peace!
- So, bye-bye!
(bright upbeat music)